What's up bro? How are you? Good to see you outside the store.
I know that where when you're running into a comedian that you don't normally
hang out with outside the store.
I mean I would recognize you but sometimes you'll meet someone that you met at a
meeting and then it's like at a Ralph and you can't place the context that's
bad.
Especially if it's like an executive and they really like you remember them or
you good at faking it? Nope. Terrible. It's your tell. I just say, I don't know.
I'm sorry. I'm sorry where you go.
It's good seeing you instead of Nice meeting you. Nope,
I've done nice meeting you. And they've go, we've met five times.
I don't even know shit.
I don't think people understand the volume of people that Comedians,
especially at your level like come across every day like how many shows we do.
People come up to you afterwards and being like, oh great, sad, blah blah blah.
And how many meetings in generals are you aware of? Dunbar's number. Oh,
is that like how many number of people? It's like a hundred or something.
So you can keep in your head, get some, I don't think it's an exact science,
but I think they think it's somewhere around 150 I believe that you got about
150 people in your head and after that you fucked. Yeah. Yeah.
It's tough. It makes sense, right?
There's no way you can keep them all in there. No, that doesn't make any sense.
It's cool. I'll tell you the store, you know, having a chat. Yeah.
It's like you,
you feel the most comradery with other comedians outside the store when you run
into them at an airport. I was just thinking about that.
Every time I go to Lex I'll bump into like someone Joe coy or last time it was
Bert Kreischer. In the case of straight over, we're going to do, I think Utah.
It's just like a hub for all of us. Yes. So you'll see so many,
cause we're all just transients.
We're here for the middle of the week and then when the weekends come for the
clubs, we're all going somewhere like,
oh we want to come to the store at Tuesday's.
Like probably the best night and people don't understand why.
Like it's so stacked. Like why is it you? Why is it Bert? Why is it Christ?
Or why is it Joey Diaz like, well we're just biding time until the weekend.
Right, and practicing. Yeah. Yeah.
It's the one of the weird art forms that you can't pray.
You can't practice alone. You have to use an audience. Yeah, don't think,
oh for sure.
And even like I'll be telling the same joke and I won't really change the words,
but it'll be like an inflection. It's almost like,
I don't know when a jazz musician or something like plays a note just a little
differently. You know? You ever notice that like a job won't work?
Maybe cause I'm, I'm like making a meal out of this word,
but if I kind of just like throw it away. Yeah. Oh now that fixes it.
It's interesting to do it long enough where you realize it's like it's not the
words. Sometimes you,
there's like a performance nuance to it to fix the joke. Like it's on paper.
It's the same joke,
but you know what's really weird is that none of this shit is written anywhere.
Like what we're talking about. You know what the worst is like I did, um,
JFL they're doing a taping out there for TV and they're like send us your
transcript. So that means you have to sit at a computer and like it, right.
It takes the magic like whatever your seven minutes you want to do for the
taping,
they want you to sit on like automatic and open up word and be like,
oh you guys doing enough or whatever. Just like type it all out.
You need a better manager. No, but I think like I, I didn't do it.
I just dodged it.
I ask Aaliyah cause I used to do it in the past and I was like, Yo,
they're asking me to write this out. It's taking all the fun and organic.
Like I feel it wouldn't really hurt my performance if I literally wrote a
transcript and I'm like a robot up there. And he was like, just don't do it.
And I go, what happens? He's like, nothing. Nothing happens.
I've done it a million times that just keep, just be dodgy.
It's some pencil pusher that doesn't make any sense. I think they get, you know,
well they have power over people that don't have a name yet.
I think they have people above them breathing down their neck and then you know,
shit rolls downhill. So then they keep on asking like, where is it? Where is it?
Change your number. Yeah. Yeah.
Well that's why I had like the reps going to be a buffer and very aloof and like
he's very busy. They can do it all. It was a direct to you thing is I would,
I would see them throughout the fast and they're lovely people.
I love these people, but like say where's they'd be like, yeah, and be like,
no, I no, I played the game a little better. I go, I'm not there yet. I'm not,
I'm not in your mother's pussy level yet.
I still got do like it's gonna go back to the hotel room.
Say it's a funny thing that your mother's posted. Yeah. Where's the transcript?
You didn't check your mother's please.
I swore that I affect your mom has a fax machine.
I thought it should be in there. Yeah, she should go check.
Check around the corner. Yeah. So it's the worst.
Having to type it out just for laughs is a weird situation. It's evolved,
right? Well yes. It's a weird way of looking at it.
It used to be very valuable for comedians.
Now it's very valuable for just for laughs because they have this enormous
platform and you go there and everybody knows that all these great comedians are
going to be there and they make an enormous amount of money off the comedians.
It used to be the comedians would go there but at the end,
because the industry would go there and the whole key to the whole thing was
development deals for sitcoms and they tossed out so much money.
I always hear about the gold rush and the heyday of JFL deals are getting thrown
out left and right and like lives were made.
I don't know that JFL but fake lives were made to like they,
they ruined it. Like,
cause I have a theory about people who aren't convenience.
Like they think they see people laughing at stuff and they see something's fun.
They think it's funny. But a comedian go, this is just tricks. Yeah.
Yeah. Well cause uh, the amount,
the volume of comedy that we want on a regular basis is so much so we can
discern like, you know, we'll talk about this, we want,
we're students of comedy, we watch a lot of comedy.
People can get like a huge pop out of the room,
but like Ian can cut through the bullshit and you know that like oh that's a
parlor trick or yeah. So it's a different type of thing.
But I think a lot of times, you know, suits and everything,
they just here decibels or right place, right time.
And they believe this lightning rod moment or whatever,
this great set is an indicative of their entire comedic being instead of like a
lucky, yeah.
Do you ever hear what is that guy's name? Was his name? Chicken?
Is that what I always hear that as an example. Like I heard you blew the roof.
He was the guy that ended it all like literally cause I think they gave him a
half a million dollars or something crazy like that.
I kind of want to see this chicken set.
Like what was the set that just blew everyone's mind?
He was a handsome fellow and he was young and he was very energetic and they
thought he was going to be the next Jim Carey. Did you see him around?
Was He an La Guy? No,
I don't know where he was from but I saw him at just for laughs.
I saw him quite a few times and uh, he was a nice guy. Yeah.
But he was terrible.
I mean in a way that like it was just a bunch of black but it,
there was no substance to it. There was no thought to it.
So they tried to put it together.
They tried to make like a development deal and he did a little touring,
but it all went south and it fell apart and he eventually committed suicide.
Do you know how many years he was doing on themself in front of a school?
That's cool. Yeah. Like, like that's what I had heard.
Like he hung himself on a tree in front of a school. Geez,
this is the last piece of performance art. I don't know if that's true.
See the thing is like,
I shouldn't even say it on a podcast and millions of people goes to, but I did,
but the hanging part is right, right. Yes. He definitely committed suicide.
It's one of those things,
men where like if it didn't work out and he didn't develop, it didn't,
he didn't, he never became like a legit comedian but thing all right over there,
Jamie. Yeah. I think if like if that had happened and he actually had,
I don't know,
the equity of a standup comedian and been doing it for a long enough, yes,
that would be like a bump in the road. But you can come back from that. Oh yeah.
If that's just sort of like your lotto ticket,
then that's why it was so drastic. I think. Well, some people are just not,
they're great comics, but they're not really into acting.
They're not the best at act, and they got kind of forced into acting.
I Love Mitch Hedberg joke. He's a great standup, you know, and they just like,
they'll come up to me and they'll be like,
can you act like that's like going up to a chef and being like, can you farm?
That's true. I mean, I'm butchering it, but there's such different things.
But it's a, you have an agent, right? And the agent wants to make money,
so it's an avenue for cash. And you know,
you look at Seinfeld and Tim Allen and Roseanne and Brett Butler and there was
all these comedians,
the 90s had made a ass load of money doing sitcoms.
Well that's the quicker pay off too. I even noticed it with my own career,
like when I was a younger comedian, I don't care.
In my early twenties when I moved from Seattle,
like when I first got reps and stuff,
I was going out on these auditions for like CW shows or just whatever.
They just throw you against the wall. You're an actor.
Comedy is this thing you do at night. This shit that you do stand up.
They probably don't even think you're funny, you know? Yeah.
It's just a cute thing you do. It's like a kid,
like a dance recital or something.
Like they don't care as long as you're going to these auditions in the daytime.
So they just hope that you hit on what,
like a series regular and then get some cashflow for the Biz. Yeah.
But luckily, I mean, I don't know.
I think you're saying your successes are carved by your failures.
So I'm kind of fortunate that I, I would get some acting things here and there,
but never anything substantial enough to take me away from stand up.
We'll never anything substantial.
The worst is when they tell you to stop doing standup because it's messing with
your acting role. Like that's, they did a Tim Allen. Oh really?
Cause his acting, who was, you know, he was on home improvement.
It was a gigantic kit. They were making kazillions of dollars, but he was a,
I don't want to say he was a blue comedian, but he,
some of it was a little risque. So how did tag it deal with it?
He stopped doing stand up. Oh, okay. So he stopped, dude.
Saget stop doing standup for ever forever.
He really didn't start doing it again until after that show was done.
I feel like it was at Shogun full house. Full House. Yeah. Yeah.
He stopped doing it for a long time and then kind of drifted his way back in and
now he does it regularly. Yeah. Yeah. I think that's, you know,
maybe they did that at the time,
but it's almost detrimental to let go because stand up is your car like it's
your business. You're in control over it and the TD stuff,
it's like one hand washes the other. If you let that go,
you're letting go of this revenue stream so that when the acting Gig is over,
you're kind of fucked cause this wasn't like building along with it you want,
it also was a point of confidence where you understand what's funny and what it
isn't like you know how to be funny because you're funny in front of a live
audience and all the time. Yeah, you're at the store. You have to be,
they're all much like you're there more than someone at your level.
You would expect someone of your level to be at. You have to be,
you can't slack off.
Everyone knows those really famous guys that slacked off and started to suck and
the good thing is nowadays, the cycle of a comedy,
we all do a special basically every two years, pretty much all of us Berber,
Kreischer, Sigora, Ari kind of.
Everybody kind of does a special or tries to do a special somewhere around every
two years, so every two years you throw it all out and you're a beginner again,
you have no fucking act. If you're terrified,
you have to come up with new premises and scramble and that requires a lot of
performing. Yeah.
I like how many rows on here talking about it was cool to hear a guy like him
even talk about just the dilution of specials where he's like,
they're not special anymore.
It's just like a flyer or like a brochure brochure that I'm still around. Yes.
It's all it is a little bit. Yeah. I mean,
obviously there's different degrees of Polish with some of the specialists and
how great some of them are, but there's so many now. It's a weird name. Special.
Yeah. We'll just leftover from yesteryear.
It's like why our albums a certain length because of the, yeah.
But at least an album is like a collection of music that is all in one thing
that you get that's kind of been consistent forever. Especial.
It's like, what is it anymore? What is it?
I guess 45 minutes to an hour of jokes strung together. Yeah.
To let everybody know. But it's also like an album,
like if you go to see Fleetwood Mac,
I don't know why the fuck came up with Fleetwood Mac. Right? Hey,
I like Fleetwood Mac. I do too.
But you're expecting the hits or as a comic you're expecting the shit that's not
on the special expecting all new stuff. Yeah. Yeah. That is interesting.
Sometimes you'll get them where they're like, do the,
that's a very rare type of ACO that's like, Gaffigan gets that for sure.
Because he's got some classic bits. And I think that also happens with um,
Russell Peters. I think he gets some requests for classic bits. You we get that.
No, I think do, I don't know how to do them anymore.
I know I purge them where they barely know. Yeah.
Someone who's yelling out Bruce Jenner the other day I was like,
I can't do that bit. I don't know how to do it. I'll fuck it up. I'm like,
you don't want it. You don't want me to do it. Sad version of,
it's like what you could remember where,
forget the taglines and Oh let me do it again. Let me start again. Redo.
Do fucked up guys. How fucked up. That's fun. You were having to go back to one.
So you are one of the rare comedians that doesn't smoke pot. Yeah, I guess so.
Talked about that and it's kind of interesting,
especially being in this industry, not taking advantage of that cause it's all,
especially the store. Like you'll do a show and they're like, hey,
you want these three bags,
these three pillowcases of weed and CBD oil and you're like,
don't take the CBD oil either. I haven't done it good. Which I,
it's great for you. What would I use it for? It's great for anxiety.
It's great for, it really reduces inflammation.
It's great for a lot of people use it for a sleep.
It's like it's just good for you. So like it's a, it's a nutrient, you know,
it's healthy for you. It's hot right now. It's very hot.
If I was in the business I'd be like, get CBD on the phone. Loves him.
I love what CBD is and do love it. Biddy how are you doing?
Canola's out CBD. Canola is bullshit. That stuff's bad for you.
Can you cook a CBD? Uh, that's a good question. I bet you can't.
I would imagine it has a low flashpoint like it would burn quickly.
Yeah. I don't know. Let's find out. I think it's usually mixed with
coconut oil as a high flashpoint weight.
Doesn't a grapeseed oil have a low grape pseudo?
I think as a high flash point too. I think it's good to cook with. Okay,
so it takes longer for it. Yeah. Okay.
It's a high temperature flat high before it smokes.
Some people said they've cooked with it, so yeah, fucking burnouts stoners,
bunch of losers, but they stink.
There's some people that do everything with weed and they need to just stop.
Where's the hemp people?
I feel like you don't hear from them as much of an area. Yeah,
there was hemp like laying in. Wait. Yeah,
it was that like the backdoor lengthens. Hemp is cool. Like what a bone. Well,
CBD is for grandma.
That's how you get people to vote for it because grandma and grandpa use it and
it helps their joints. Right. And they're like, well, I'll tell you what,
this CBD, I mean, it's not doing anything from a brain. You're not getting high,
but my joints never felt bad or feel amazing. The CBD,
and I'm going to vote for it and I've really want to get ahold of Trump and let
them know that's not bad. See Bay days,
it really is a region from
[inaudible] guy. Yeah. It's random.
Random old guy from the middle of nowhere.
CBD does revolutionize nutrition and really fucked up my life in a very positive
way. I think people use little south, maybe Maryland, maybe somewhere,
outskirts of Baltimore and people don't know you have that gear or you forget
like you do voices really well, I don't have that many though.
I can only do a few. I think.
Are you the type though where if you're doing a bit and you need this person to
talk or whatever, you'll you'll figure it out. Yeah, I can get a few.
There's a few voices I can get out. Yeah, yeah.
Cause you're Alex Jones and like you get along so well.
I've known Alex for like more than 20 years, so it's less easy. Yeah.
I've hung out with that guy. We've been hammered together so many times.
It's like, that is the most misunderstood guy on the planet.
He just needs somebody next to him. That's what he needs someone to go, Alex,
let's slow down like you were. You had a really good point there.
You need a manager who's always with them. He even agreed with me.
We talked about it. I said,
you just need like a rational journalist who's next to you to like stop.
He goes, you're right. You're right. You're right. I do need that. I go just,
you need someone who's just even closes out. Look, he was right about all this.
Jeffrey Epstein, Shit. That is a fucking fact.
Alex Jones called this years ago, years ago,
he was saying that they take a lot of famous people to this island and they have
all these young girls that this guy hooks them up with.
He was talking about this years ago now it is mainstream news and this human
hybrid did experiments on on, which sounded like a complete joke when he said,
write it up. We were like, we were like, what? Now it's fucking mainstream news.
This is a fact, man. We like,
people want to write that guy off because he'll tell you he's crazy.
He'll let you know. He's crazy. I mean,
on my show there was one of the finest things he ever said. He's like, look,
I want to be honest with you. I'm kind of retarded and I fell to the ground lap,
but that's who he really is, man. People just have him lumped in, you know?
It's like some people,
they don't represent the best aspects of themselves write to people and then
other people try to define them like people try to define you.
It's really one of the things that it's really kind of weird about.
The more famous you get,
the more people try to define you in a way that's detrimental or a way that's
dismissive and limiting.
Like I've noticed that after this Bernie Sanders thing that I did,
so anybody listening to this, if you're saying this,
I am not right wing at all. So stop saying that. It's silly. It's foolish.
I've interviewed right-wing people. I am 100% left wing.
The only thing that stops me from,
the only things that I disagree with about left wing people is support for the
military support for police in the second amendment. That's probably it.
Everything else across the board,
I lean way left in terms of like Bernie Sanders made a ton of sense to me and I
would 100% vote for him. Tulsi Gabbert is my favorite. I mean I'm not,
I'm not a right wing person. So this nonsense,
like so many people were saying that, you know,
Bernie Sanders spent this time on a right wing podcast. Like what,
what are you saying and don't you think he weighed the pros and cons of like it
was an opportunity for him and I think everyone thought it was a win.
I don't think you had any idea who I was really? Yeah.
I think it was one of his young staff members who's friends with Kyle Kalinsky
who is a,
a really good left wing progressive talk show guy on youtube and Kyle hooked it
all up and um, this, this idea that,
you know, it's bad for someone to talk to people. It's just, it's foolish.
This is a weird thing that's going on right now.
I thought it was a great platform for him to like get his ideas out there and to
be heard and something other than just soundbites. Yes,
it could be taken out of context.
It's a great platform I think for anyone who's running for anything to have a
long form conversation. And it's good for us too,
because we get to find out who they really are.
You really can't hide in a long conversation. You have three hours,
you can't tell an hour and 10 with Bern. That's all he had.
Cause you know the guy's running for, he's legit running for PR.
Like he could be president. Right. He's not like, you know,
like there's some people that are running for president, like, all right bro.
You know, like what does that Guy Zoltan what is his name?
He was the guy who was running a, the transhumanist platform.
Ish. Davon. How'd he say his last name? Very nice guy.
And sorry for this coming out. It was the last one.
It was 2016 and we had them on, but you know,
it was like one of those guys where like, all right, like Ben Glee and be like,
alright, good luck. Do you think Ben's gonna win? Um, oh I do. Okay. Oh yeah,
but you gotta respect the swing. That's what's great about this country.
You know, I swing the swing. What are you talking about?
You could run for president. No, no, not,
that's kind of just like anybody could run for president. Yeah.
And it sounds far fetched, like, yeah. Okay. But I mean,
you've got to be crazy enough to think you can be. You well look,
anything can and will happen when it comes to being president.
Like people get assassinated, people get exposed as being a criminal.
Like look,
do you remember when Michael [inaudible] was the hero of the left?
The Democratic Party was like,
he's the guy that's going to run against Donald Trump and he's going to take him
down because he's tough and he's just, and he's gotten Michael [inaudible].
I mean that there's a compilation of left wing pundits talking about the hero
that is Michael Avid, Nordea.
You don't hear a fucking word from that guy anymore.
So if you are in a time capsule, right? A year ago when everyone was Michael,
avid, Adi, crazy. And they just shoot. And then when they woke you up for him,
it's 12 months later and you'd be like looking at the news, hey, where's,
where's that Guy Naughty? I mean, I was, that happens. I went all in.
They'll have their champion and then this other shit,
you know drr there's always they ascend and then there's some like dark shit
from the past and then you don't see them anymore. But then there's guys that,
you know,
like one of the things that I was getting at during the Trump campaign,
he's running for president. The
first time I was like, this guy's not going away. Like this is not going away.
He knows what he's doing. He knows how to fuck people. Like how, how like, uh,
early in the campaign did you kind of realize, I don't know man, but my also,
did you, do you feel like you had um, a better read on it?
Just doing stand up across the country?
Cause I feel like you could be in a bubble.
You could be in New York and La and just be like,
oh that's never going to happen. This is ridiculous. Yeah.
But doing stand up in some red states, you kind of, you're with the people,
you're doing jokes and like you get a temperature of,
of an audience more so than someone who just has like a desk job
for sure. But also I have a lot of right wing friends,
a lot of right wing friends, especially from the hunting world.
I have a lot of friends that live in,
like I have friends that live in Iowa and Oregon and they have a lot of right
wing friends too and there's a whole part of the country that the big cities,
New York and Los Angeles and the, the big d democratic leaning cities,
they were all dismissing that the Democrats thought that Hillary was the most
experienced and Trump was a buffoon and that that grab her by the pussy tape.
That was it. We got it. It's in the bag. They all believe that,
but the middle of the country did not believe in her. They didn't trust her.
They thought she was some sleazy politician who's been involved in the business
forever and she licks her finger and figures out which way the wind's blowing
and that's what she says and that they,
they thought that Trump was a straight shooter and he's going to train that
swamp and he's going to do this and bring jobs back and he's talking about clean
coal. Yeah.
It's almost like, I think you're just so outside of the system like a,
it seemed like he could have done anything just like we want someone to throw a
wrench into it.
Yes, that's it.
There's a lot of people that just wanted a wrench thrown into it and he
definitely threw a wrench into it and I think ultimately that's going to be good
for the left as well because they're going to realize that you can't just get
away with that same stupid old school politician style of doing it anymore.
I think he's just blown up the playbook. Even even a like Bernie calling Trump,
was it stupid or an idiot in a post or something like amazing.
This is a new paradigm. Yes. Like they're adopting.
They're taking pages out of what worked for Trump. Yeah, look, we've got to,
we've got to take some bully tactics and then even a Moscow, Mitch, I'm like,
oh, they get it.
Nicknames are the only thing that stick yelling and begging the rally.
Like Moscow, Mitch like, yeah, this is part of the playbook now.
Sleepy Joe Biden. Yeah. That's my favorite.
It's as evolved as we like to think that we get as adults.
When it comes to politics, it goes back to grade school.
The only thing that seems to be effective is yelling Moscow Mitch or you know,
sleepy Joe Biden or Pocahontas.
These are these like stand up rules. Just like Rickles. Just, yeah.
It's so interesting.
And W W my fear about the Pocahontas one was when people were saying that he's
racist for calling Elizabeth Warren Pocahontas. It's a Disney movie.
You can't, you can't,
you can't go that far and call me a, I'd be juice. Aladdin's cool. He is,
he has a whole monkey. Keeley eats apples. Yes. Did you see the man? I did.
It was pretty good. Yeah. Cut Bad reviews. I didn't understand it.
People don't like what they did. They felt I,
what I read was that will Smith modernized it too much? What does that mean?
Like I prefer a classic genie. Oh, they used modern urban vernacular.
They just weren't uncomfortable with that. You remember how, um, you know,
the first photos came out of will Smith as a genie?
I love how little it takes to whip this nation into a frenzy.
Like I'll wake up and open up Twitter and then the will Smith genie.
Everyone is freaking out over that and it's crazy how,
how we put them on the same pedestal,
like some sort of Trump scandal or like pedophile island and then the blue genie
or sonic looks weird. Sonic the hedgehog alone. Both.
Both take on the same amount of fervor on the same amount of psychic energy.
Yeah. Yeah. One of my,
I think one of the biggest gaffes biggest mistakes ever was Ben Affleck thinking
he could be Batman. If Ben Affleck never ran for Batman,
he would have 50% less hate. You think some people who liked or no?
Was it no one who liked that Affleck as Batman.
Even Ben Affleck didn't like himself.
When was the last time you heard anybody talk about Ben Affleck as Batman?
Ready go? Yeah.
No one Christian Bale's Batman motherfucker.
Even Michael Keaton's Batman, but he's old. That's so hard though.
You know like you're not going to hit a home run with Batman every time.
Would anybody who does it and fails their career hits a ditch. Who Do you think?
All right. Do you think, okay, Kilmer leveled up or no, from Batman. Well,
Kilmer did it once and he did a good job, but then he decided to get fat.
He's like, fuck this business. What about crazy seeing the top gun movie,
the new one? I hope so. I hope to. That'd be great.
Although the lady's not in it. The girlfriend, the really hot blonde.
What was her name? Kelly something. Another Miguelez. Is that it? Yeah,
she was beautiful back in the day.
I think she might've gone the vow killer route for know what I'm saying?
What about the Clooney? Clooney,
Heh, clique. Come selling Nespresso and
Tequila Nespresso. He's his was like a comedic take.
Arnold Schwarzenegger weight made way more money than George Clooney in that
movie. Huh? Oh, me and my buddies, we have a thing.
We just say cool with Paul t like we just say it to each other no matter what
party we're at. What does that, Alicia Silverstone,
she was in that and Chris O'Donnell, but why did I forget about that?
He was Robyn. Now he's on a TV show with Elequil j.
What does that one is that it?
It's like a NCS or something that is something that the same people who talk
like that guy was making fun of, but that's what they DVR that. Oh, oh.
Like once you get to certain parts of the country isn't an interesting to find
out what their favorite shows are. Yeah. Yeah.
That's where all those NCI s shows,
that's where they get all their millions of views. Sure. That's wonderful show.
Chris does a great job and he just pairs well with ll cool J who's [inaudible].
He's a little aggressive to me. I mean, it's all right.
He's a good foul I guess, but I really love Chris. I wish we'd get more work.
We should bring them back to the movies or I thank you.
Be an excellent Captain Kirk. He could be captain Kirk
also like I lived at my aunt's house and that's just playing all the time.
Like burn note. I mean that's not even yours anymore,
but like does USA shows Jag number Jag, my God, Jan reruns of Jag,
my brother shows on Jag. Love it.
How the thing is like we can laugh about these fails, but they're like 20 seat
Jag was on for 20 seasons. We were just going over survivor. The other day.
Survivor was on when fear factor debuted,
it was already on the air and that fear factor came out in 2001 or two somewhere
around right after September 11th I remember that cause I remember being asked
questions like,
was it appropriate to have a show about fear after September 11th my dad, some,
some guy asked me that. I literally wanted to climb through the phone,
strangled them. I'm like, you fucking bitch. What was your answer though?
That's nonsense. What if he walking back stupid? You're like, I'm sorry,
I didn't know that fear would play such a factor for you.
Um, but so survivor's been on,
what do we say it was 28,000 seasons on a 39th, I believe.
39 seasons. It's still going. Yes. You didn't even know. No,
I think the amazing racist they'll go on to. Do you remember that shot is? Yeah,
CBS is killing it. That one won the award every year for the Emmy's.
Like best show up or best games show whatever reality is.
I don't know what it did it, but yeah. Wow. 12 times in a row or something.
Crazy. Did you like fear factor more than,
cause I remember I loved news. Radio like goes on my favorite shows.
So did you enjoy that more fear factor?
Are there different things that are definitely different things?
I enjoyed the paycheck from fear factor far more. Um,
I liked working with that actors, but I love news radio way more.
News radio was just a far better show, so it was a really good, well,
they're different things. They're very different animals. It ruined me.
It would. It would.
It's like going from the comedy store to uncle fuck's sticks, chuckle, hut,
and on a Monday night, you know, it's like every other sit-com that I looked at,
every other sitcom that I read for or that I got scripts for, rather I was like,
Ooh, this is just not good stuff.
Isn't it interesting when you get sides like just sides.
It just like one scene or two scenes for a show and you could tell it's good
just from that. Oh yeah. That's so rare. It is rare. Yeah.
When someone's a good writer, good Sitcom. Writing is hard to do. Man.
That is a really hard gig. I mean there's a, and then,
but then some people have bad sit-com writing, but they know how to make a bad,
successful sitcom. Like there's bad successful sitcoms lasts forever.
They're just unoffensive enough to stay on the air and keep you watching with
your mouth. Slack, I mean formulas exist for a reason.
Those big bang kids, they're so, they're so clever with their riding.
That's what keeps me doing the, I'm waiting for the vocabulary, the labs.
This guy ever shut off CBS the whole time I tried it,
but they're too hostile. Did you know that your TV has other channels there?
Yeah, there's other channels.
Other programming you could watch when they took bill O'Reilly out the air.
CBS is my channel. That's my channel now. Yeah.
You ever been in the looking audition and it's terrible.
But everyone goes through the motions where from just like cracking up like
it's, oh look, it's the greatest show on her. Like it's def jam.
Like cause the writers and the directors on the room like the fake,
like get everybody excited. Yeah. The half to,
cause I think they need this rocket fuel to get this project off the ground and
they need to give the writer confidence.
They have to give the director confidence.
They have to give the studio people confidence that it's all good.
It's a fake moment. The fake laugh. It's gross. And the thing is though,
like it's also not only is the girl still, but it's the 30th time there.
There's just this,
there's 30 people in the waiting room and they're laughing like it's the first
time they're faking it left and right. And we know fake labs we do.
It's offensive. So fake laughing at you. It's almost worse than Chanel laugh.
It is worse than not laughing at all. If you say a joke in there like, ah, oh,
he like, get them out. You get out of here, you bad person, you, you, you,
you use the quickest way to heckle though, right? Just like, ah, ah,
no one can say anything laughing. Yeah. It's like the Fredo thing. No,
I talked to him was freedom. That freedom,
the freedom thing I was talking about, but I thought that you afraid of,
did you see that? Yeah, of course. You see a jacket that
Chris Cuomo Guy Jonelle Trump had the best line today.
Donald Trump won the internet today with this. He said,
should we red flag Chris Cuomo because he seemed unhinged.
He was using terrible language, should not have a gun.
He basically exposed those red flag laws. He goes like, you see a guy like that?
He's irrational. That guy's irrational. He goes, I'll wreck your shit.
I'll throw you down stairs. The stairs comment. That was, I enjoyed that.
Like what is he talking about?
Cause the guy called you Fredo and he was saying that the freeness sees the n
word. I didn't know Frito was drug Tori or I may have, I'm new to it. I just,
I'm not that I would ever try to call someone Fredo sometimes you know,
it's a fucking character in a movie. It's like a Latin. Is it like a,
there's no like, I don't know, cultural context, Italian.
There's no cultural context for Fredo where people like what the fuck did you
tag? That doesn't exist. It does not exist.
Well you could say it for someone who's a trader,
but why that doesn't even make sense with Chris Cuomo. It's just,
it's just a loser in a, in a movie. Well I guess like,
you know what he's trying to do, I mean obviously he's trying to insult him.
Yes. Even if there is no history of this word existing for,
you know, I'm ignorant. I don't know if it does exist or not, but like,
you know, this guy is trying to take shots. It's certainly not a compliment.
Sure. Yeah. I mean it's a loser in a movie.
It's a brother that always fell short and he turned it turned on his own
brother. Who is the Godfather? What if his, he wanted to be the godfather.
What if he explained this insult to Chris Cuomo? That would be great.
It was Frito was a weak Italian in the movie.
And I feel referencing your character,
you are the son of a great man because you know,
he's Mario Cuomo son and you probably, you know, let's,
let's be honest about why you're here. You know,
the name is familiar and you know, it helps. Yeah, but it's,
it's that uh,
Tahlia Ian Energy that like, again, this is my people.
These are my full Italian, no, not three quarters though.
But these people that,
that react that way are common. It's like,
what the fuck did you say to me? What y'all fucking wrecked your shit?
But you're not supposed to be a respected political pundit and behave like that.
That is nonsense. That's nonsense. That's nonsense.
It's a silly way to behave. It's silly. That guy needs to work out.
It's tough. It's tough when not too much testosterone.
So we need to take him to tell the doctor, just pair you down a little bit.
Take whatever you at. Just drop it by half settled down bro.
Or just work out really hard before you go outside. Do some yoga. Meditate.
I like when those, uh, cause Ellie's pretty passive town for the most part.
You'll get some of those, you'll get like an east coast guy and you're like,
oh shit. Who's this guy? You know what I mean? Yeah.
Like visiting from out of town. Like whoa Nolan. Hey Freido. Yeah,
we don't actually fight here. We just go get my shine box. Yeah.
It's um, it was a very embarrassing moment,
but I think it's a very important moment. Look at him. First of all,
he is Fredo for life now.
I hope he understands that he's frayed though for light.
Unless you want to get tossed down a flight of stairs.
You Ain't tossing anybody down a flight of stairs. That's nonsense.
He doesn't want to get sued. He's not going to do that.
It's not gonna touch somebody.
You hire someone that flight of stairs not doing shit,
not doing a God damn thing. That's one of the reasons why it's so funny.
He's not doing nothing. That is Fredo. You'll never get away from that.
Now better embrace that shit.
Better start selling Frito t-shirts with your face. Listen,
CNN is probably going to fire them. I would imagine they're standing behind him.
The fuck out of here. Are they really for,
and I think they felt like he was attacked or unprovoked. Yeah.
By someone calling afraid though. Yeah, man, look, I'm fighting wars, dude.
Someone called me Fado. I'm even an Italian. I'd snap. I go, how dare you? He,
he's a silly man that that's what would exposes him and said he's a silly man.
It wasn't like someone was
being equally aggressive to him and he was defending himself. Sometimes,
like if you're in a situation where someone's very aggressive to you,
you almost have to be aggressive back just to let them know, hey,
I'll go there with you. Yes we could.
We could go to a dark place right now and you know I'm not going to let you hit
me.
I'm not going to let you do something to me if you think that I'm a pushover,
you know I'm here to defend myself,
but that wasn't that way like someone was mocking him and he turned violence.
It was a little bit of a complex situation where he just wanted to get a rise
and he was recording from down low. He,
they wanted him to do something that really Chris Cuomo, this is CNN.
CNN has lost their fucking mind.
Chris Cuomo defended himself when he was verbally attacked with the use of an
ethnic slur in an orchestrated setup. The spokesperson said,
we completely support him for now. Listen to me, this is not done.
This is not done. This is just beginning to take on a form of its own.
You can't, you can't say that's an ethnic slur.
That is a fucking character in a movie. News to me and I was like,
fuck decks and him saying that. That's like calling it the n word.
That is so preposterous. That is so offensively stupid.
Do you ever get that? Like uh,
people trying to take shots or get you to slip or something?
Most people are nice. Yeah, for the most part.
I've had guys say goofy shit to me and I tried to say goofy shit back to that.
Get shells or just on the street or what and both things. But I'm not in a,
I'm not a hostile person. I look hostile,
but I'm not hostile. Like I'm nice for the most,
I've had people get dicky with me. And then what do you do?
How do you handle it? Get Dickie back. Just like, yeah,
you see all three on a flex day. I don't say that. It's just, it's not,
it never escalates to that. It's like some people get weird, you know,
it gets weird. The fucking autograph people at the airport, how do they like,
would you be surprised sometimes somebody off somebody when you pay somebody
off, what do you do with you sign or do you just keep on telling my son one,
I'll sign one and get mad at me. I've got to stock in these. I go, no,
no I'm not working for you. Not working for you.
Like there's people that charge people,
they'll go to those conventions and they'll sit at a booth.
They'll charge someone x amount of dollars.
Like it's like 20 bucks or more for an autograph photo. I don't do that.
I'm not going to do that ever. So I'm not, I'm not, I don't,
I don't even want you selling my picture. I don't want it to be sold.
I don't want my autograph to be valuable. But if, if I felt,
if I thought someone was really a fan and they wanted me to sign something cause
different, yes, I would sign something for him. It'd be happy to,
instead of like a four year old guy with a ponytail and a stack of stack of
fucking photos of me and various, you're selling those,
I know you're selling those. So some guy,
one guy got mad at me and he was like following me around lax. I was like, dude,
I'm not signing anymore. It's like next time I see you okay. I'm like,
I'm not signing, but you know my mind going one of them,
you're making it very valuable. If you sign the whole stack, fine.
I tell him I'm not going to be rude, I'm not going to be rude,
so I'm just trying to like, look,
I'll sign one and I tell them that like I got a bunch of them in Portland this
weekend. They were, there was like 10 people met me at the airport,
so I'll sign one. I think one is good, but I ran into the guy in Philadelphia,
they got, he tried to get me to sign another one. I go, I'm not sign on that,
and then he goes, he goes, [inaudible] you fuck with, forget your friends. I go,
you're not a fan. I go, you're selling needs. You'll see what you think.
They're worth a lot. I go up there, why you here?
That this is a weird mental gymnastics like just to do better.
You fucking autographs worth about six 45 I go and you're a MOOC. I go,
you're over here trying to get me to work for you. I'll go get a job.
And so we had this like weird conversation. Like what are you saying?
You want me to sign these so you could sell them,
but you're saying they're not worth anything. So I'm a loser.
But you're meeting me at the airport to try to get me to sell things.
The sign that my flight is this. It's so silly. It's so silly.
But I just don't like the idea of it because primarily I don't like the idea
that there's some weird loophole where someone can get you to work for them.
They're just showing up and your sign these real quick and I'm gonna sell them.
Cause it's you. You're asking someone to work for you.
Even if it only takes five minutes or they're taking some off.
One guy had 30 pictures hit 30 back. How many you got there? He goes 30 I go,
you out of your fucking mind. How funny would it be if you,
if you sat at a Starbucks and you just did them all,
oh you're like hold on family. I'm just going to get through these.
The UFC makes fighters do that. They sit down and they,
but they give them out the fans and they do stuff with them.
Promotional materials, not one guy and everybody signs,
I'm like all the fighters in the card sign them and you know they're valuable to
fans as a fan. Like I have,
I have a sign poster out there from Efrin Rayez that I purchased and Efron Reyes
is like the world's greatest pool player.
I love pool and he's this a Filipino wizard. They call him the wizard.
He's amazing pool player. So I signed,
I bought it like it was signed by Ephemera. It's, I got so excited,
but I would never ask Efrin to sign something and then salary and track them
down to the airport. Someone at the, at the,
at the promotion for the tournament,
they probably got them to sign a bunch of them.
They sell them and it probably was helped offset the costs and things along
those lines.
But there's this [inaudible] that the autograph collector is a different animal
than the autograph seller. So if you're a person that is just like,
I love Raheem's comedy's really funny.
I want to go to the comedy store and see if I get him to sign something for me.
That's a fan for sure. But if you have 30 of them,
you're going to go on Ebay and you gonna try to make 50 bucks.
That's what you're doing. Well, you're not going to make 50 bucks.
I'm going to tell you right now. They might,
if they hold onto to sit on the air. A funny guy. I have a lot of talent.
What have you seen? I'm always surprised cause like I came to the store,
I always see it, the store, you know, and you're like, oh man,
your videos are funny. And like I don't know what you watch,
you're just going to tell their level. I don't think it even reaches you.
Oh that's nonsense. That that other level thing is a complete total illusion.
I'm here to tell everyone no, cause you are a rarity.
I think of the Comedians of the store who have gotten to a certain point where
you kind of have a relationship with everyone at the comedy store,
from the door guy to the waitress is to like, you know,
stand up like me or like Santina or Ian like you,
you have relationship with everyone. You come through,
you spend time at the store,
you're being pulled by a lot of things like UFC and a family and all this stuff,
the podcast. But you will hang at the store. Well that's a community.
It's very important to me that that community means it means a lot.
It means a lot. Um, and I like,
I like supporting the up and coming people. I think it's very important.
I think, um, all the door people, the guys worked a lot.
Those guys are all there. We're all gonna work together someday. You know,
it's very possible they'll, they'll be, you know, I'll be at one theater,
there'll be at another theater, you know, I'll be at a club over here,
there'll be the club over there. We're all the same. It's just an illusion.
It's just time. And I think it comes from martial arts because in martial arts,
everybody trains together. You know, I'm a black belt in Jujitsu,
but I'm as friendly to the white belts as I am to other black poets.
We shake hands, we hug. If I roll, I'll roll with a guy who's new.
It's just starting now. Give him tips. I'll help him out. You know,
we're all in it together.
And I feel like that's the approach that I take with comedy. The same approach.
I don't believe in this elitist shit. I think it's stupid.
I think it's, it's bad for everybody.
It's bad for the person who becomes elite even more so than it's bad for the up
and coming. Cause the amber commerce, if you don't,
if you dismiss up and comers and you treat them like shit,
like you treat them like you're better than them, you're above them.
You don't need to like talk to them. You don't make eye contact with them.
You ignore them when they're trying to talk to you.
And I've seen that from comics and um, I think it's bad for you. It,
for them, it just makes them angry. You know, they can't wait until,
and I have been in that position before where someone's dismissed me and been
shitty to me.
And then I surpassed them fame wise and then passed by and then they become
friendly and weird with you. And you need to kind of remember. Yeah,
it's very strange to see the one 80 you'll be in comedy long enough to see
plenty of one eighties and it's not, I mean you'll,
I'll give you some names after the show. Oh really? Yeah, yeah.
Name some good names. And then you,
you act however the relationship is now at this point in time. Yeah.
But that's always in the back of your mind. You're like,
I remember when it was not this, but there's,
there's also I want to give someone an opportunity for redemption.
Like I want to believe that they've changed. So I've, it's hard.
I don't want to be that mean person is like that.
Fuck that guy for life for sure. For sure.
But I do like hopefully that they grow. Let me,
maybe they've grown as a person and they'd been humbled because the career kind
of like skid and came to an abrupt halt and they're trying to rebuild the,
used to be someone that thought that they could. There was a time, um,
mostly pre-internet where comics looked forward to doing a couple things.
One for one thing they look forward to is bumping people and doing a lot of
time. Yup. They liked, but the bumping people was the big part.
It wasn't just doing time. So like you're doing a time thing. If you,
if like Dave Chappelle calls up and says, I want to do a half an hour,
nobody cares. Like he's two. He'll wait till,
like everyone's calling up and then he'll go home at the end of the night.
He's a beautiful person. I love that guy to death. He's,
he's the exception to the superstar rule cause he's a sweetheart of a guy.
But there are some that wanted that spot of the bumper where they could just
show up. Oh my God, Mike's here. Mike's here for him. I'm sorry.
Mike's going up. Mike has to go up and Mike looks at you like I'm going up.
You know, like there's a few of those like that fed them, feeds them,
feeds them to let them let you know that you're not on their level. Yeah, I,
I've heard of like that happens way less now. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well first of all, because people like us talk about it on podcasts.
Like if this one guy that was like a super dick to you and you're like,
let me tell you something Joe, there's a fucking guy, you know, it's,
we're all comics man. Just like when you go to a Jujitsu school,
you take a class or two classes, you're a fucking martial artist, you know,
you might suck, but you're a martial artist. If you're up on that goddamn stage,
your comic in my eyes, you're just like me. I'm just,
I've been doing it for 30 years and you've been doing it for less. Yeah. Yeah.
That's what it is. That's the, that's the only difference.
It's just a time in and if you get 30 years down in what you get out of those 30
years is that you're better than everybody and that you can act like you're
better than everybody and you're aloof and you're dismissive.
You've missed everything. Beautiful. Like when I come to the store I like,
could I get hugs?
Yeah. Yeah. It's always hard cause when you first start coming back, I'm like,
uh, I would just think like I'd be on the wall or whatever. But you're like, Yo,
what's up? It's up to him. I'm like, give me a hug. You know?
And like we haven't really like talked a ton but that something as little as
that goes so far.
Well that's nice. Yeah. I hope it does go far. I'm want,
I want comics to feel good about the community that we have.
Yeah, I remember cause when I got past the store it was the dark ages.
Like I know the stories had various dark ages,
Bobby talks about like the 90s and stuff, but you are at the ice house.
So like you weren't even really part of the story.
You were still just like going there a lot. Yeah. Yeah.
So it was very cool for you to come back and then Adam take over and then it
just kind of evolve into what it is now.
It's crazy because I remember when it was not that and there was kind of a
beauty in it though. I'm like pretty fortunate in hindsight that it got past.
Then what year was this?
I think I got passed in like 2010 that was three years into the dark ages.
The Dark Ages, sorry, 2007 uh, yeah. Yeah.
It's also crazy to like know that you know the history and see the video and
then, oh, I exist on this timeline now. The store was just, you know,
when I'm living in Seattle, it's this far away place.
Even Hollywood and entertainment and all that.
It's just this place that exists on a box. It's not real. It isn't.
It isn't right. This isn't a real thing.
And then you move to La and I'm hanging with the Improv. I'm a ghost. You know,
people are walking through me. You know when you first come to town,
I swear to God, like I'm literally, I'm like, I do comedy.
You go in there walking through me and I'm just like my hands on it and I would
just hang out. And that's part of the deal. You just have,
you realize leaving your apartment is a win in itself.
Like you may not be getting
up as much as you want to, but even just like being out,
it's a win because I want to be like, oh, you should do my, you know,
cause out of sight, out of mind. Yep. So I would, as a lawyer at the Improv,
I was nobody. And then I was like,
it was like Sandler and someone and like maybe Kevin James,
I think Sandler and Kevin James. And that was like,
I'm sure that's very standard. I mean, I've been here so long,
it's a very standard now you see a million people like I a very,
I don't get star struck at all, but it just kind of like, oh fuck,
those are people in a box.
Other people in the box that I watch and they just walked in.
So that was kind of like a little mind fucking adjustment, you know? Well,
when I was in Boston in 1988 when I started,
Mecca was the store man.
That was where prior performed and Sam Kinison and Hicks started out there and
Hicks, he's do stats, he was a doorman there and you know,
Letterman was there and Robin Williams was there. It was just, it was Maca.
And I thought when I first started doing comedy, when I first,
when I realized like, okay, this is what I want to do.
Like after the first set I ever did, I was like, okay, this is what I'm doing.
I'm doing this now I'm, I'm, I'm all in. You know,
it took me awhile to get funny,
but I mean I had it in my head that I was going to get the con,
the comedy store. Oh yeah. And then when I finally got there,
I remember thinking how surreal it was. Cause I was like,
I guess I was 26 25 no,
25 or 26 I think the first time I stepped foot in the store and I remember
sitting in the back of the room going, Holy Shit,
I can't fucking believe I'm here. Isn't it odd? It's, it's just the place.
Yeah. But it isn't, it's not, it's not just a place. I know,
but like when you, I guess the manifestation of the place, like okay, the stage,
there's chairs, there's a table. You ever see it in the daytime. All right,
this is [inaudible]. It's odd. It feels like it's waiting.
Yeah. Like it's waiting, but it doesn't come alive until nighttime. Yeah.
It's like a, a bedded animal, like a hibernating bear.
And at nighttime, man, the drink start clinking and you know, the,
the comedy starts flowing and Jeff starts playing the piano.
It's an interesting room too. When you first started doing it,
was it difficult because it's not a net, it's not, um,
it's not an easy room or zone. These, yeah, the alarm. I consider the alarm.
The comedy store. Yes. People will come through and be like, Oh yeah,
I've been to the store. I go, I go, what, what rooms? We're like,
we'll go to the main room. Okay, cool. My name is cool,
but it's not the heart and soul of the comedy store. The Omar is intimate.
Nothing gets lost. Right. The main room, you kind of have to be,
it's so big and there's that second tier.
You know how the step goes up to like be able to have that laugh wave hit that
back row. Yeah. You're really working.
Your performing and the stage is so big.
You have to be more theatrical to kind of do a serviceable job in that room.
But in the Alar,
it's like literally you're just watching a man gathering or a woman, you know,
just like you can be real. You can be, you don't have to be like, right.
You don't have to predict as much. Yeah. Yeah.
Well there's different kinds of comedy, right?
What's the largest crowd you've ever done?
I've been watching your stories and stuff and that's fucking insane.
It's like even when you're in the green room and you just hear these murmurs,
it sounds like, you know,
like an angry mom is going to kill yourself and use your honor. Ah, it's called,
they're all just like filtering into this giant theater.
Maybe 3000 or 4,000 and that was, that was a trip that's big.
But you notice when you do 3000 or 4,000 that there's like you have to give them
more pause. Oh yeah. More time for the set. The, the, the joke.
The punchline is settle the last to settle before you move on to another.
But what another great about doing it so long is stand up is this conversation
with the audience. So you know, to wait like you have inherent timing.
Yeah.
Another comic would just kind of know the timing of the club and just like plow
into the next joke while they're still getting laughs from a theater. Yeah.
You can't do that. But I took,
I was talking about this yesterday with Tom Papa that one of the reasons, uh,
one of the best lessons that I ever had was actually sitting in the audience at
one of Richard, uh, uh, not Richard Lewis Black's not Richard Lewis in the,
of confusing. I mean I was confused. Yeah, for sure. The word Lewis, uh,
Lewis Black Show in New Jersey.
He was there the night before me and Joey Diaz and I sat in the audience and he
would hit a punchline and people would laugh and then he,
he would hit the tag and I couldn't hear the tag cause all the other people were
laughing around us and I was like, oh,
like you gotta be like a little more selective. Yeah.
You can't just hammer them like in the store at the o r you can hammer them
punchline, punchline, punchline, punchline,
and you could beat the fucking shit out of them that way.
And it's a different kind of comedy. If you have that style of comedy,
you might struggle a little bit with the theater and you'll definitely struggle
in an arena. Arenas and amphitheaters or another animal.
I feel like just having no ceiling. How does that work?
Cause I did a Saturday night. That's San Francisco. I had a great time.
We had a great time. Allie Ma, Alan Kowski killed. She had a great time.
Ian Killed. It was fun. It was fun. But it's definitely different yet.
I think it's different because I think there's such fans and obviously they're
going to be tuned in. Yeah, that helps. It's different when you're like,
I'll do some festivals sometimes or,
I mean back in the day you would do a college or something and it's just outside
and if they don't know who the fuck you are. Yeah,
and it's daytime and it's outside. Yeah. You flew to pick up a check.
All you gotta do is not lose your mind on stage and you can collect your check.
If you're like, like then you're not getting your money.
Well it's a matter of whether or not your having fun.
If you are having fun and you enjoy performing and you your materials good.
So you know it's good, you can have fun and whoever's tweeting and,
and have a good time and the absurdity of the situation is funny. Um,
but honestly it's not going to be like a regular club set or something. Yeah.
Dude, I'll take you,
if you want to come, I'll take you, I'll take you one of the crazy,
I mean that just seems like such a mind trip.
That'd be like a standup float tank, you know, Alli's only 22. Yeah,
she's so young. Yeah. And I, I've been taking her with me,
her and Ian Kayla's weekend and the first arena she ever did.
Well, here's alley, right? She's done clubs with me.
She does Improv with me all the time. She has a store with me all the time.
She was the door to door beauty of the system at the store.
It's like one of the last places like that where there's a system in place and
Yep. Yeah.
She works the door of the store and she performed in front of 10,000 people on
Friday. And then went back to checking ids.
That's the mind fuck of being a young comic.
Do these crazy things and then you're back at your job.
But she's wild and hungry and she's, I don't worry about Allie. She's fine.
She's great. She's really down to two. But um, you know,
so the first big show she had done before that was the Mirage in Vegas.
I love that clothes. I love that club.
I started doing that club and then I went to bigger arenas and I came back to
that club because it was so much fun because most of the time when I do Vegas,
I do it the night before. UFC like on Friday night. And uh,
I was doing these big giant places like the coffee theater,
which is like a hundred foot tall seat, more than a hundred feet tall ceiling.
It's a Cirque de Solei place. But it was too weird. It wasn't,
it wasn't the right setup for comedy. And the Mirage is so perfect.
I just a Terry Fado. Yes, yes, yes, yes. So I went back to,
so that was the first time she'd ever done anything big and she walked out there
like she fucking owned the place. She's like, she owned it. Yeah. She's like,
she had a bat, the best set I ever saw her have there. And then I said,
okay, you want to do an arenas? She's like, ah. So yeah,
that's balling. So we did this crazy place in Portland.
Portland wasn't the same man. God Damn owes off the charts.
Almost too big. Almost two, two powers, almost too big, but almost too powerful.
Did they do concerts in there normally or what does that space basketball.
Oh Shit. That's where the blazers play. Yeah, for real. Yeah. Whoa.
You'll be great if they just have a tee shirt cannon before you're set.
You're like, yeah. I had a, my buddy cam Hanes who lives in Eugene,
which is real close to there,
was in that same place a couple of weeks before that for a game and he's like,
dude, I can't fucking believe you're coming here to do comedy.
Like what is this? Yeah, it was nuts.
You would almost think as like a consumer of comedy.
What is that experience like?
And is it still like the beats I've gotta be so different than like a club?
Like that was fun man.
I was watching Ian on stage and he was murdering and I was laughing my ass off.
It was great. It's all in the acoustics of the building.
And the Moda Center in Portland is a really new theater or a new arena. It's,
it's really well made. So the acoustics are excellent. There's nothing is lost.
Cause that's my world like in a space that big that no one can hear what you're
saying. And it's muddled. And I've done some big places where it's not the best.
I've done some big where you hear a little
echo and you're like, Ooh, this could be a problem.
So you have to be a little clearer with what you say.
Like you almost got to take some of the spice out of your joke, you know,
a spice out of your delivery because it's, um, it's a little echoey.
The best though, the best is the ice house or the store or the Improv,
like 200 people, 300 people, Bam, Bam.
And it's like comedy clubs are a certain size [inaudible]. If it ain't broke,
don't fix it. It's also cause that's all they could see.
I mean it's hard to sell like Prov like Joe Rogan,
comedy clubs and they're all like 20,000 seats. They're like, yeah,
I mean it sounds like when Joe comes around and we're having a tough time
getting people to come out, it's, I mean how many,
there's not that many people that are doing those places like Kevin Hart,
Dave and like, oh that's so crazy too. Like you guys teaming up to do a tour.
Sure. Comedy Fan. How great is that dude?
We did 25,000 people in Tacoma.
We broke the all, he got my brothers right. He hit up Ian and Ian was like,
cause I think I was, I was in London so I was sleeping like the time is off.
So then he just DMD Ian and he was like, Hey, I'm thinking brother,
can I come to the show?
The date things are crazy though because he brings a DJ and Don l Rollins gets
out there and gets everybody hyped up and it's the fucking Djs in between the
sats charge. It's like he's getting into the next level.
So next level it's a concert. Yeah, positive. Just you feel crazy.
Like is this really high? Like even Dave, he was like,
this is fucking crazy man. Like we were all like this is the game.
This is crazy. We were all like, this was crazy.
We all realized this was something cause people were so pumped that we're doing
it together. It was mad. It's like a,
like the watch the throne tour and Kanye and Jay Z. Yeah. Yeah.
We're going to do more. We're try to figure out where and how,
but we had a great fucking time and why not? So rock star Shit. They,
they show up at places and have ivs ready.
They do intravenous vitamin infusions with glutathione and how to be 12 shots.
How did you feel after like I could run through a [inaudible] ball tree out of
its roots.
How did you feel before and then after we just like tired, you know,
we're traveling and we're up late the night before and then you get juiced up
with vitamins and you just, you're like, where's that tree? Yeah.
You feel fucking excellent. This, I guess,
you know they don't rock stars know what they're doing. Yeah.
And I'm sure you're only doing a fraction of what they do.
They're doing coke and they have something different in IB.
They probably have some other bag we don't even know about. Probably. Yeah,
it was probably some illegal shit. Yeah. Like they probably do an Nad.
They're probably doing a lot of different things. Yeah. Yeah.
But it looks insane at the end of the day though, back to the grind.
Like tonight I'm doing the belly room. You know, it's so funny.
You just back in the belly, back in the belly room, two in the belly room.
Then I'm telling the Improv, I've got at 10 30 at the Improv tank. Double Dip.
Yes. Always. You ever do? You don't do factory early? Huh? I don't do the fact.
Is that cause they tape? Yes. Okay. Yeah, they taped me. They tape everybody.
They put your shit online, but like we're not going to do it any more.
But they still have the camera up. [inaudible] do you just not trust them?
Because like they'll send it to me with the clips and I'll be like, I don't,
it's not ready or I don't want to put it out there. And then they respect it.
So Bill Burger said, yeah. And then I found this shit online. I'm, Oh yeah,
look at that. And he's like, what the fuck? I was like, yeah man.
Well like somebody working there that's not listening to this, you know?
And maybe they don't do that anymore and I hope they don't, but don't.
Why chance? It just doesn't feel good. It's just that,
especially the way it was handled, it was very poor.
The way it was handled was like,
you should be happy that we're putting it online. It was not good.
I'll tell you all about it later. But it's just,
there's plenty of room at the Improv and the store. I don't need to go there.
I don't wish it, I mean, I hope it does. Well. It's a great club.
It's fun to work at. Sure. You know. I know what you mean though.
It's like I'm in Tarzana now and like someone will be like, Hey,
do you want to do this show in Irvine? And that's just like saying,
my shows on Mars are fine at eight o'clock.
You might as well leave your house yesterday. Like bird, can you chop our Meta?
Yeah. Termite in a chopper with car. No, you gotta go. I was working at Boeing.
I had a coworker who was learning. Uh, well he,
he had his hours up and everything, so he flew,
he flew choppers and during our lunch break he's like,
you want to go on the chopper? Jesus. I was like, sure. So then he's like,
let's take the doors off. What? Kill you? Nah,
but like in my mind it was crazy. I figured, why not?
I'm going to go on a chopper. That's true. So from my lunch break,
I went into chopper with this guy. I recorded it. Wow. And then I said,
then my mom saw it and she just like flipped out. She was like,
[inaudible].
Yeah.
If I had a a son and I was a woman and my little boy was in a plane flying over
the doors, off the doors off,
maybe you didn't surf and on the way and told her like that, it was my coworker.
Yeah. Yeah. You should have said it was like a super experienced fighter pilot.
He, he's a military guy. Yeah. He's have 20 years experience. Yeah. Yeah.
It's weird when you go up in a, in a bird with like someone, you know though.
So, well, I did at first in high school. One was in high school, my,
my friend Mike, Mike wore bell who was a,
taken a small plane lessons and we flew around this little small plane.
We just like fucking, he was my age. Maybe he was older than me. One year,
I think I was 16 he was 17 maybe. Maybe. But no more than that.
And he's got to trust him.
And you're like flying in a fucking plane and he had a copilot.
It was like an instructor. So he was texting better than, yeah,
it was taking lessons him.
But that was the first time I was ever in a little tiny ass plane.
It was in high school. You don't want to do that. I have no desire to do that.
It seems like a rough way to die. I just don't like,
even with all the training and all that, just truck, I'll leave it to the pros,
like if JFK couldn't do it. Well I think the JFK
story was more complicated. I think he was involved with a fee.
I think that that flight was like no visibility.
I think you ran into fog and like a more experienced pilot would have known the
weather conditions the best to be going up. Yes. And also you,
you have to understand how to read the gauges because you gotta know what
altitude you're at and the gauges have to be 100% functional. And yeah,
I don't know what the whole story was with his death, but I believe Google,
whether or not j f k his body had cocaine in it. Google that.
No RF. K, what's his name? Jay. Jim. Joe Jr. Not RFK.
JFK Jr his body had cocaine in it.
Cause I think there was some cocaine involved, if I'm not mistaken. It's like,
fuck, I can fly into the clouds.
I'm in the clouds pick that didn't even have any like lessons,
but he's just like [inaudible] I think he knew how to fly and I think he was,
I think he was unprepared for no, it's, you know how it is.
Like he was off the Cape, right?
It wasn't somewhere near Massachusetts that fucking, those clouds get thick bro.
I mean, you don't see Jack Shit.
So you're flying around in that like imagine just fly, right.
You want 500 miles an hour and right in front of you is white.
That's all you see. 500 rounds down through the white. And just knowing,
kind of just knowing this isn't a good situation. Yeah.
You're fucked and you kind of know. Yeah, yeah. Well, when I lived in Colorado,
I remember there was a time that I was driving up this hill.
We were pretty high up. We're about 8,000 feet above sea levels,
3000 feet above boulder. And as we're driving through the hills,
up to the house,
the fucking clouds were so thick you couldn't see five feet in front of the car.
So you're driving on a mountain road that sometimes has no railings to the left
it to the right and it's just death to the left and you're driving up this
mountain road and you can't see Jack Shit.
So you literally have to turn the fog lights on.
So the regular headlights are no good.
You gotta shut those off and you have to have fog lights on cause fog lights
just kind of light the ground and that's why they exist that like people,
it was like people don't even think of what a fog light is.
Cause most of the time you don't really have to deal with fog.
Fog light is a little light down below.
You could see a little bit instead of blinding it just with that.
Otherwise you just see bright white. Did he say anything about that?
But they were full check info wars.com I want you to go to the wrong source.
Did you use Google being at Jamie eight 39 at night
and they were flying over a water that had no features so they were over water.
It was dark and foggy.
It was basically pitch black and he didn't have a flight plan either and he,
he told an instructor that offered to go with him. He wanted to do it alone. Oh,
but you didn't find anything about cocaine?
I googled that and nothing popped up,
but it's something popped up that they might have had a past of that,
but nothing said autopsy. Nothing said that. Okay.
Maybe I made it up. It's possible. Let's put it in the Wikipedia page.
Just my memory varies so wildly. It's,
and I'm wondering if it's old age or if it's just,
just an overwhelming amount of data in my brain and my hard drive is just
completely run out of space. Maybe there's some overlap,
like a similar story for sure. There is because I,
I'll have conversations with someone sometimes and uh, they'll ask me,
we'll be just talking about something like, oh,
well that's not exactly how it happened. This is what happened.
And because of this, and because as they evolve,
they develop the ability to do this and that. And I'm, I just had, I know this,
I'm like, why do I know if somebody goes, what do you a fucking biologist?
I'm like, no, I'm an idiot. Yeah, I do remember things,
but I don't retain some things.
Sometimes I forget who I was talking to or who said what or how, where,
where this idea came from. It's weird. It's not slash selective man.
It's not that good. It's like, but it helps when I'm taking nootropics,
which I didn't today, today, I didn't take any Alpha brain. We don't,
why don't we have any here? How come you don't have any here? Oh, gimme no,
thank you. Oh Man. How does this work? Well,
your brain's going to grow. Hope your head can really, it's flexible.
Just like flexible. The headphones are swell from the head a lot.
You used to use a used to rather throw this in here. Yeah. Yeah.
You used to work at Boeing. Is this like an Elon Musk moment guys? No.
Am I going to be a mural? I know, right? Isn't that crazy? Yeah. Mural
crazy for me too. I mean, I didn't even think twice about giving him weed.
Really? You didn't think like, oh, this will be a moment. It was just,
I thought it was just hanging out.
Me and my buddy Ilan smoking a little wheat like normal,
like the stockholders are like, no, all the time you see the bras,
banes painting in the Green Room. We're in the cloud. It's a 6% oh no. Yeah,
go look at the smoke cloud again because he lost 6% of the stock gs,
but he got it back.
It was up to 9% the next day went up 3% his street cred went fucking through the
roof. Dude, I drove his car here. That guy deserves everything he gets.
That car is a god new time machine. I'm still a Mazda three, 2007 man myself.
Ooh, I'm a, I'm a purists. Nice.
Sometimes I'll get a brochure in the mail like get the 2019 Mazda three you
know, I'm going to put a bullet in my head. If I get two Mazda threes in a row,
don't get a Mazda three but getting them, Yada, Yada, Yada, hope those are dope.
Isn't that like a punchline? I don't give a fuck who is making that joke.
They don't know what they're talking about. [inaudible] making fun of me.
Bullshit to to Miana is a fucking fantastic car. I'm not bullshitting.
It has very low horsepower, but it's super likely. This will be my like defense.
Some people make fun of me. They have a lot of horsepower.
It's really lightweight, doesn't have a lot of route. It's very low.
I think it's less than 200 horsepower under an 81 it's but Miatas are amazing
cars, but as one how many times do you hear as a punch line? Those are hacks.
Those comedians is, they're funny.
There's certain words that are just like go to like Chappellet lays a great is
chipotle is a great punchline card. They still make them in a, in,
in a standard with a standard transmission.
Just want to say thank you mom or your welcome Mazda for Dita fucking great car,
man. I'm not kidding. They're really fun to drive. They handle really well.
I like mine. I'm going very tactile,
but a Mazda three is different than them yet. All right.
How much different is it? I mean probably pretty different. What does that one?
That one right there. The 2019 Mazda mx five Amex five Miana.
What about the Rx to see that red one? The cool red color? Yeah, but good.
The one above that, please look at that with the removable roof. Ooh,
that's like a target. It could be on the beach with her. That is a dope car.
People are crazy. They just want it. They want higher horsepower.
If that was instead of a Miata, if that was a Tesla, Tesla made a,
an electric Miata that goes zero to 60 in one second. Get on.
Everybody would want that car. Yeah. Dude, it's a great car. Drive one.
All right. You don't want to do.
I'm going to test drive a Mazda Miata go to and it's cheap.
How much does it Miata? It's like 28 Grand Jew, man. Come on man.
I'm not bullshitting for 28 grand. You get a great car. I'm not kidding.
I would drive a fucking Yoda.
I just would never think that you would have this much passion about the Muslim
Jada and it's really refreshing. I am an automobile enthusiast.
I love cars. So the car is here. I love engineering. I'm a fan.
Do I know you? Oh yeah. I love mechanical things.
I love how people design things and what they've done with the Miata is they've
made a car that it always has a loyal fan base that continues to buy them
because they don't break the bank.
It's not something that you pull up to the club and everybody thinks you're like
some super baller, but it's a fun car to drive.
There are really fun car to drive. They're super lightweight,
they're very agile to handle. Great.
They still make them with a manual transmission line stick. Yeah, they're fine,
man. It's a fun car to drive. Don't be hating on me. Honest. All right,
body fill up Mazda three. I want the same love for the month. Not that good.
What the fuck? Kind of boring. It's like you might as well get a Prius. Yeah,
you're in the Prius category. You know what's happened with Tesla?
It's interesting because when you,
for a while you could be driving a Prius and no one knew if you are rich or
poor. It was the great equalizer. Still This Day,
Larry David drives as fuck for sure. But Tesla came along and they were like,
Yo, now you can stunt and save the earth.
Now people know you're rich and pious before you didn't know if this guy's poor
or DiCaprio. Yeah, but now it's like,
so all the poor guys who want to go green are kind of fucked.
But a Prius is different because it's a hybrid yet,
like that was the only option. Back in the day. That was the only option.
Mercedes has a an s class Mercedes,
top of the food chain Mercedes. That's also a plugin hybrid.
It's just the new one that they just released,
like Jeremy Clarkson was raving about it.
It's supposed to be this incredible car.
So Mercedes is actually making like plugin hybrids for their top of the food
chain vehicles. That's pretty cool. It's pretty, seems like that's cool. It is.
It is new, but it's also, it's like a little bit of a step back because it has
what the step up is going to be about a car that charges and it charges an
enormous amount of time, like an hour or two. How long get 600 forever.
We have a supercharger here.
We have a supercharger installed here and it still takes, I dunno,
probably five hours. Five hours dead. If it's dead,
it'll probably take five hours, maybe six you know,
but like if I come here and like full charge is,
what is it get 300 and fucking 90 miles or something like that.
Somewhere around that range. Are you not really,
are you having to be a little better with your planning? Like all right,
I'm going to put it in here. I'm not going anywhere with it. I go to La.
I go to the comedy store like I have like this weekend I'm in Anaheim for the
UFC. I'm not driving that fucking you crazy. I'm not getting stranded.
I happened to get stranded batteries that have electricity. Concise.
Anybody can sit here with me for eight hours. Yeah,
there's not a God damn thing you can do.
You have to call a tow truck and they have to bring it to a charging station and
then you have to sit there like an asshole. It's for six hours. It's a,
but the technology, if you can't look,
obviously I'm kidding in some way because it's super simple. It's got,
you've seen one the inside where the giant screen.
I've only seen from the outside cause like the colon right here. Go sit in it.
Cause the comedy store has turned into a Tesla dealership. It's kind of hot,
you know? [inaudible]
you know the store isn't a renaissance where it's like so many tests coming in
and out of that place. Not just Tesla.
It's like Russell Peters pulls up in a Ferrari SUV. Plato just got a Bentley,
a Ferrari. Oh No. A Lamborghini Lamborghini SUV.
Now must be the most trying time to be a lot guy at the comedy store.
Just imagine the bullets they sweat having to move because that parking lot in
the comedy store, it's like tetris.
There's a finite amount of space and they've got to fit all the paid regulars
cars in there. And the problem is the price tag and all these are insane.
Now the problem is they're letting these promoters park there.
Oh aren't they being better about about saying like you can't park in a lot.
They should detonate their cars. They should have like,
like instead of a tow truck that's just like a stick of dynamite to giant like
Kevlar tarp that they throw those cars and just detonate them.
It's just during your set. You just do it.
Like I'm just kidding promoter cause there's so many people that parked back
there like you're not even a comic. Like what are you doing?
Not only that though,
like the back bar and that sold the back area get weird cause that's like our
home. That's kind where,
where we hang out before we have to go on stage and we want to see you guys like
you or Santana and just like chop it up before we have to go on stage.
And then it's like who's this?
And they talk to you and they interrupt conversations and not in a snooty way,
but it is a bit of a way. It's like a dugout. It's like a baseball dugout.
Adderall people go back. Yeah, they talked too much too. Yeah. You don't need
that in your life. Right. But they actually,
they have more confidence than me back there.
I'm like [inaudible] they have Adderall confidence. I've never done that at all.
Have you done it? Isn't it big now? Like every student has taken it.
A lot of people are taking it. It's a big thing amongst journalists,
journalists, writers. Cause they get more work done because you're on speed.
Like there was a guy that I had in here that was a writing a book on,
he wrote that book on Hunter s Thompson. Um, what does that, uh,
what does it, what is, what does this book
something Gonzo something. Anyway, um,
he was talking about how he needs it to write and he can't write without it.
Is it just the deadlines and the workload is insane and that's a way to kind of
cope with it. You don't need it to, right. Can you move your fingers?
You lose your shares. Yes. Are you alive? Fatigue? Yes.
Take a break. Go for a walk. That's the natural thing to do.
But some people want a quick fix. Well, it's not necessarily a quick fix.
It's like you can get a gun. Timothy didn't Evie yet. It's nice tire.
Very nice mental debt. If you keep on taking it.
What's the name of the book? Yeah. Mental debt. Yeah.
It's called you become a crack head freaking freak. Kingdom.
You become someone who is on stimulants all the time.
And I know several people that have an issue.
I know one guy has completely lost his fucking mind.
Thinks everybody's against him, thinks that, uh,
everyone's done him wrong and he's just out there cracked out in the middle of
nowhere.
On fucking Adderall every day and making youtube videos and there's a lot of
people like that, man. There's a lot of people like that.
It is a meth like drug. It's very, very, very,
very similar to meth. Yeah.
It's just a different release in terms of like the how quickly your body
processes crazy, how widespread it is for something like that.
Then it's fucking stimulants. Man Gets people.
If you can effectively do your job and you don't commit any crimes and a,
they can sell you that stuff and make a profit and then you actually are more
profitable when you're on that stuff than not than fucking have at it.
That's how people look at things and like that. Look, when I was, uh,
when pop was sort of legal, when it was medically legal,
I had a bullshit prescription. Your back hurt. Oh yeah. Everything Bro.
That's actually a matter of African. I used a bunch of different ones.
You go to the hot doctor, you know, like you would see on sunset boulevard.
It's like this, like Persian chick is like, no. Describe, you know,
I went to a black dude with dreadlocks. He was awesome. He,
this is what he looked at me and when I went in that's the best.
We ducked her to the blanket like, oh, this guy's good the best. He had a,
do you remember those vaporizers that are, they're a bag.
They're called the volcano.
I remember when I stayed with Ra chef here in New York and he,
he had those and I had never seen that before.
Just seemed like such an odd contraption.
Some of the early podcasts we vaporized with that bag and they're the dumbest
conversations because we had no idea what we're talking about.
I would like correct myself halfway into a sentence because I forgot what I was
saying and then I would forget what the original correction was and then I'd be
what else? No, that's not what I'm saying. What am I saying?
I was so fucked up and it would take like an hour into the podcast before,
like the fog would settle.
So was that just the medical marijuana delivery system? Well, no,
it's just a delivery system. It's not meant.
You can use it right now and you don't have to. I feel like, dude,
people use it that way. Really vaporize what those bags, what's the,
I don't know, upside of that. No smoke. You're not, you're just getting missed.
You're basically getting the THC crystals.
It's turning into mist and when you vaporize,
you're not getting the burnt plant material. Almost like harsh on a sewers.
There's a million ways to get what you need or wine dorks or cigar dorks.
It's like real similar. But anyway,
I walked into this guy's office and he's just the fucking coolest.
I wish I kept in touch with this dude who was, uh, somewhere in Hollywood.
I forget where it was, but they do look to me, goes, you look sick,
you're sick. He goes, you need some medicine,
you need some medicine. And he had his big smile on face. I said, thank you sir.
I feel sick and I feel like I need some medicine. He goes,
what are you here for a brother? And I said, uh, it helps you sleep. He goes,
good enough for me. And he wrote a prescription. He gives me a prescription.
Then he pulls out the biggest bag.
He hit accustomed vaporizer bag for the volcano. And I'm telling you,
I'm not exaggerating, it was four feet long. She says is four feet long bag.
He puts it on this,
like if it pumps up like a kids bouncing house fills up with weed,
he does it there. Oh yeah. We were blasted. We got blasted at his place. Um,
the doctor's office was connected to a grow up, right? So we, we smoke,
we smoke, we vaporized, right?
And then we'd go into the back where they're growing the wheat and we're
barbecued, right? I'm barely in this dimension.
And I go in there and I see all these plants and I get a feeling from these
things like they're alive. Like they're conscious.
It felt so weird to this day. I missed that feeling. I go up, maybe it was that,
was I so high I was hallucinating.
Is it or is it possible that if you get really high on pot and then you go
around the pot leaves,
you pick up their frequency and you understand that they're a living organism.
And that's one of the reasons why they make you feel so good when you get high.
Like one of the reasons why you're interact,
you're interacting with whatever they are with the molecules,
the THC and the Canab anoints, you're interacting with it.
And then when you go around the actual potted plants and they're all super
healthy cause they got this crazy hydroponics set up and they're all the right
nutrients and now these blush green plants and it's perfect environment for
growing cause you know they're experts and I'm like these things are alive man.
These things like they're, they know you're there. They're like, Huh.
So it was that. So it was a successful trip. Oh yeah man, I was,
I took me hours before I knew what I was doing afterwards.
It's like hours later trying to figure out,
oh I just love how he took the onus of an excuse off of you. Oh yeah.
Yo look sick. That's stop
moment. I walked in like you look sick,
you looks you need some medicine and crazy dreadlocks and circular glasses.
He was amazing. God, I wish I kept in touch with that. Good doctor.
He was a great doctor. I've had a bunch of good weed doctors.
I had one of them though. I had to stop going. He went crazy nine 11 on me.
What does that mean? He, when he was trying to tell me that the,
the towers were brought down by Tesla technology and I was like, what?
He's like, concrete doesn't vaporize. I was like, what do you mean vaporized?
I said try to do a bit about like how like, you know,
you hear about white privilege and everything. I go,
one of the things about white privilege people don't really think about that
much is you're allowed to have any conspiracy theory you want.
I can't be like nine 11 was an inside job. You know,
like jet fuel can't melt steel beams. They're like whatever.
I'll come and sure thing. Aladdin. No, you don't understand dead's different.
Yep. Yeah.
If you looked at the pie chart of people that are really into conspiracies and
like looked at race white would be overwhelming.
What would it be like the pie chart of conspiracy theorists? Yeah. I Dunno.
Like three quarters of the pie chart. White people. Yeah. Just,
it would sound absurd coming from me. Like I don't believe that.
But imagine if I'm like nine 11 wasn't, you know, it was a brown guy.
Like they're like share thing. You're not getting off that easy inside.
Yeah. It's a, you, you worked for Boeing's I what you do? What,
what did you do over there? I was an aerospace engineer.
Were you involved at all in nine 11? Did you have anything to do John?
I'm Outta here. Ken.
Tell us your lulling me into a false sense of security with like the comedy and
the comedy store here is, I've been your friends anyways. Uh,
you were involved in nine 11. What did you train those pilots you gave me?
What did you do? What'd you do at Boeing? I did stress analysis. Oh,
we're the floor.
It's a very unglamorous the thing with like a kind of cool though, I guess. So.
Um, you're bonafide. Smart. Yeah.
I mean I'm able to jump through hoops with a goal in mind.
Like I have a high threshold for academic pain, so I took a lot of math.
I took a lot of, it wasn't that hard for me. It was like, I mean,
it's difficult to get the degree, but all right, they do these steps,
you get this number, there's this formula, you have the tools,
they show you how to do it. Monkey see monkey do.
Interesting way to describe it.
And you have a high threshold for academic pink cause it is like a little
painful. Right. I think just,
it seems so daunting to the average person and they just don't want to be
bothered with that. To even get over the hump of learning something like that.
They're just like, I could never, that's for brainiacs.
But the thing is engineering was a means to an end for me to do stand up comedy.
Like my parents were gonna pay for my college, but only certain degrees.
So at first, because I knew I wanted to do stand up when I was like 17. Really?
Yeah. How'd you know? Uh, I think two things happen.
So I didn't grow up with standup.
I didn't really know it was a thing that was on my radar.
I grew up at the Simpsons, SNL and, and like Kona late-night Konan. Those were,
those are my jams. I feel like that's my comedy. Um, DNA.
But then I'll 17 till I get my 17th birthday. We rented delirious,
so we watched delirious Eddie Murphy's delirious, you know, just fuck.
It was like the greatest thing in the world.
And that just planted the seed of comedy.
So that coupled with my love for SNL and I'm like, how do I, I like,
I don't know if Google was around even or maybe, I don't know.
I just research how do people get on SNL? Maybe Google was around.
So I saw they came from two camps.
They were either stand ups where they came from, uh, Improv.
So like second city, UCB, Groundlings.
This was like the pedigree. These are the schools they picked from.
And then I researched those schools. They were in Chicago, La, New York.
You had to pay money to take these classes. Um, you may not pass,
you have to go back to one oh one or whatever. So it's like,
it's like a school and stand up is just you just you out there.
We'll take a sword, you know? Yeah. So I like, I'm like,
oh I could do that and there's comedy clubs in Seattle. I can count on me.
Like I don't have to rely on other people to like Zip Zap zoop with each other.
Improv is a great thing, you know? I'm not like knocking or anything.
It's just a, it's such a different,
you have to dedicate your life to like one or the other.
I think it was very hard to be great at both and there's not a lot of career
paths for Improv. It's like getting to a certain spot and that's it.
There's some people who are very,
very talented in Groundlings in like UCB and then how do they monetize that?
If they book a commercial, they're still beholden to a lot of other people.
They have to be the right guy or girl, the right look.
There are so many variables that are outside of your control as a talented
improv performer, but as a standup, you could do a weekend.
We can always make money once you get to a certain level famous like in terms of
going on the road as an Improv guy,
I guess as whose line is it anyway guys do it. Yeah, but you, you'll have to,
maybe they'll, they'll start doing stand up because they've built some,
you'll see that, right. They'll build some credibility,
like a notoriety and they come from the Improv background,
but if they want to start making some money on the road,
they start doing stand up.
But they're no better off than someone like a 22 year old doing standup now
because you got to put the hours in just because you're good at this other
thing. You still have to start over. Right. It's like the farm. Yeah, yeah,
exactly. You got, you can't, um, the beauty of standards, you can't skip steps.
It's so when you see a comic on stage,
it's like when you cut a tree open and you see all the rings,
you could just tell like, oh, this guy's been doing it 20 years. Yes.
You can't fake that. Yeah.
So I chose to do stand up because it was just me out there and I could rely on
me and I could do it while I do engineering school.
So I chose engineering because like I knew I wanted to do this stuff,
so I thought I needed a theater degree. So I was like, can I do theater?
And my dad was like, no, you can't do theater.
And then I kept getting more and more watered down. I was like,
can I do like directing? Like, no, you can't. Just direct things.
I told you what you can and can't do. Yeah. And I love it. In hindsight,
I'm so grateful, dude. If I had an a theater degree right now,
I'd be fucked.
If anyone's watching and you have a theater degree or you're thinking about
getting a theater degree, don't do it. You don't need it.
You're not going to be Jude law because you have a theater degree.
You could do it on the side.
Think of how many people have come to la or New York. It's a different thing.
Okay, look,
if you're at Julliard and you're this instrument or whatever and it's like a
top, top, top theater school, and it's a theater to like that world.
Okay. Or if you're the son of like a huge actor or daughter.
Sure. But if you're like in, I dunno,
Ohio and you're going to theater to school,
you're just lighting your parents' money on fire, that's all you're doing.
They're letting you like go on a 20 year old jungle gym for four years.
The thing is like you see sometimes like an actor like or rather like an athlete
or someone will be an actor and a movie and they'll do a fucking amazing job.
Here's the thing, like Oprah, here's an example. Color purple.
The highest paid actor is the rock. What? Theater school?
Dwayne, the Rock Johnson. Go to the theater of hard knocks. Thank you.
So you might as well do wrestling as opposed to, so it doesn't,
theater degree does not equal acting job. Right?
But that's a different kind of acting than say like Jake Glen Allen Hall or
sure. I mean, yeah. Do you think you're learning that at all? Like,
here's the other thing too that I always thought was so interesting because I
did act in class for like two months when I was here in La, you know,
just to try it out and stuff. It wasn't for me.
And what's funny is like there'll be teaching these techniques and like Mies
narrow tapping in and blah blah blah.
And then at the end of the class there'll be like, all right,
does anybody have any sides? They want any auditions,
they want to go over and it's all just CSI. Interrogation job's like,
I don't know the guy.
So you're like you're teaching Shakespeare class and anything anyone's ever
going out for is like, oh yeah,
I used to come around here like two times a week.
Like how is I am big pentameter helping you with that's, that's what you're,
and you're chomping at the bit to get this long order.
CSI delivery guy number two, why are you learning Meisner? Right.
And I know there are no bit parts, only been actors and all that. Was it true?
No. That's what actor, that's what I'm acting. Teachers will love to tell you,
when you complain about getting a bit part, like got they go,
there are no bit parts, only bit actors, and then you go, oh,
I don't want to be bit actor. I'm happy to be a tree.
Well, there's certain comics will tell you there are no bad crowds.
Those people are assholes. Sure. I think we've been,
the thing is if you're a younger comic and you're, you're like a crop sucked,
you don't have the bandwidth to know what's good and bad yet. Not yet.
So you can say that.
I can say that like we've all seen bad crowds. Sure.
And we can chalk it up for what it is.
But if you're a year end or a two years in, it was Mo,
it was probably you not, um,
audible ing or just like adjusting on the fly does every, yeah.
Very good. Yeah. Maybe that too. Sure, sure. That's a,
there's a weird thing about comics where there's certain comics where, you know,
there's no way they're going to figure it out. I don't know though,
because I mean as a whole, yes. But there are, I,
I hear there's anomalies from that.
Like cause I would hear stories about Sebastian,
which is so crazy cause I wasn't there for that timeline of one.
But he's killing it. He's so funny. You know? And he's like the guy now.
Well he was never terrible. Okay. So you're talking about like, no,
I remember Sebastian in the beginning. He was never terrible. He was learning.
I see. But he was,
he showed up all the time and he was always a nice guy and he's like,
he wasn't terrible. He just didn't do great in the beginning.
I think people just take liberties with that story then and they make it sound
like, yeah, no, he was never offensively on funny. Right.
Certain people that are offensively on funny where you're like,
there's not a chance you are, you're missing the DNA. Like you just can't,
you're color blind. You're missing it. Whatever it is. You don't have it. Yeah.
Can't breathe. I mean that's the beauty.
I would hear Mitzi stories of her just telling people like, we are in tear ball.
You've never met her, Huh? No,
I got there when Tommy was around and it was kind of, so she was still,
she was like sick, you know. And he would say,
Nancy saw your tay and I don't know if she, I know, I know, I know. Yeah.
So he would always just like have this buffer between like Mitzi and myself.
And I would pretend that Mitzi was, she became like a,
what's the guy's name from psycho Norman Bates. What's his legs?
And mom was in the fucking shower, but it was really him, you know,
like his mom's dead and he would put the wig on. That was Tommy.
Tommy put the Mitzi wig on and then he wouldn't,
he would always like do her voice and stuff.
And like when giving and dude like,
cause he would expunge wisdom and cause I remember I would drive up from Boeing.
That was my, so I was working in Long Beach. Oh yes.
I've got an engineering degree. Right. And then I just applied to jobs.
I did mechanical engineering cause my best friend was doing mechanical and I was
like, I don't care what engineering I do. I just,
I'll be close about it to my friend.
And you were just doing that so you could have a job so you could make time for
myself, it was such a long con. It's like, alright,
I knew I wanted to do stand up. Um, in the meantime I got to go to college.
Right. I've gotta be able to support so I can get good in Seattle.
Really funny man. I guess people don't, um, do that.
Life's a long time if you're lucky, you know? Yeah.
And it's okay to have to plan this far out. It sounds Farfetch.
Maybe if I told it to someone at the time,
but in hindsight it was the most beautifully executed plan. So yeah.
So I did stand up while I was going to college. My life was just um,
school by day, stand up at night.
It would actually be stand up on the weekends cause I was living at home and
it's 40 minutes of the club,
so I would just do a lot of time on Friday and Saturday. Did your parents know?
Yeah, they knew and it was bad. It was like a,
I was doing heroin like they were against it. Wow. Just because I feel now,
um, my mom has, I took her to the premiere, I had a small role in whiskey,
tango, Foxtrot, this Tina Fey movie.
So I took her to the premiere in New York and so she got to be on the red carpet
and like take pictures with Tina Fey and like, and so she, she was in,
she was in after that and she keeps on asking me, she's like,
when's the next premiere? Well, you know, I'm available.
Thanks for me or that
there was an after party and everyone's milling about. And then my mom's like,
there's Tina. Tina's like, introduce me. I'm like, yeah, okay, I'll come home.
Cause I'm like, my mom's a sweetheart, but I'm,
I'm still caught in this showbiz thing. Like I'm,
what number 15 on the call sheet or I'm married.
I wouldn't even know if she remembers me even though the movie, you know,
so I'm like, I got to pick my spot. And then she just kind of like nudges me.
You're like a linebacker. She's like, pushes me into Tina. I'm like, oh,
but it was great to have the out of my mom be like, my mom is such a huge fan.
And she was like, Oh yeah, of course. And she was a sweetheart. So now she's in,
she's in, she's like, you made it, you're, you're, you're actually, yeah,
she could see the light at the end of the tunnel, like, okay. And what your dad?
My Dad, my dad is kind of more nuts and bolts. He doesn't,
he doesn't like get fooled by the gluten, the glamour, anything like that.
He just understands money and things. Like,
I've had a nice car that Mazda, if I had a Mazda Miata,
I mean he'd be fucking soul like you did okay. But no, get a Tesla.
Yeah, I guess so. I think what, what has soften him a little bit,
cause I just got this place in Tarzana,
like a house and that's like real adult shit.
So I didn't realize that would kind of, um,
soften him a bit because how old do you know? 35 so you're like, wow,
he's a real adult. I guess so. Yeah. Do you have a girlfriend? No.
So when you get married, I don't know if he cares about the hell.
Like I think it adult does. I think my dad cares more about the security, like,
like a real career, uh,
income and a house and stability when the comedy was never that.
And then also aside from just those things, you know,
they're from Afghanistan so it's a low,
in my dad's opinion it's kind of a low thing is like a low thing for someone to
be doing. Like oh yeah, like low, like um, sub subhuman
cause he would always say cause all you had like a giant sold-out theater.
I don't know, maybe. Yeah, who knows? But his line of people waiting to see you,
I guess. I don't know what that thing will be, but he would,
he would always say, cause we would, you know,
be in shouting matches when we were younger. Oh yeah. When I was younger. Yeah.
I mean look, I love my parents and I know what it was grounded in.
I think they just, they didn't want me to be eating out of a dumpster.
So they were just, they were there. I mean,
most of my dad's his frustration and lashing out or just like,
not like physical or anything. Just like, you know,
like you're throwing your life away, blah, blah, blah.
Was cause he wanted that security for me. Yeah. I understand it for what it is.
When I was like 17 or 18. Yeah. You know, you don't get me right.
Like it just feels so now that I'm older, I get it.
I get where he's coming from. Yeah. So never had it.
The point was, but I think now that I have a little more stability
[inaudible] say, um, he's like, they, he's like,
you're out there every night with the pimps and the prostitutes.
I don't think my dad's ever been to a comedy club.
You see a pimp at the comedy store.
I might've seen one or two prostitutes over the last 20 years out there.
And every night, pimps and prostitutes,
that was his line. You should talk about this on stage.
He didn't like my last special I taught, I tell that story. I talk,
I talk about this story with my dad and he would always trot that out there.
I mean he's not half wrong. He's half wrong. He's half.
I've seen a couple of prostitutes share,
but that sounds like as long as there's no pimps.
I've seen maybe two or three prostitutes in the whole front rows.
Just like for coats. Oh, I'm like canes. Oh Oh,
grease. Big Diamond Rings. He would say,
he says people should be entertaining you. That would be the thing.
Like I should be the one entertained. Cause you're intelligent I guess.
So you're a serious person.
Like I just found like if you want to make broad strokes,
I think in the Middle Eastern community it's um,
like they love art but they're kids shouldn't be doing it like they should be.
They should be consumers of art. Oh, interesting.
But what if you were like a famous painter, classical painter, I guess. No one,
no parent really thinks best case scenario for their kid. Like ever once,
once people buy his art, it's always like, it's a pipe dream. What are the odds?
Blah blah, blah.
You're throwing your life away and I guess there is some statistically sure
statistic. Sure.
But I think like what I would do different when I have kids or whatever,
I would, I would explain the realities of how, you know,
the whole theater degree thing. I,
I'm so glad they made me do a degree with teeth because that allowed me to have
a legitimate job to get me out here. Like I'm not a trust fund kid.
How else would I be close to where I needed to be? I needed to be here.
They're in Seattle. They're still up there. They're still there. Yeah. Yeah. So,
so I would have some practicality. I'd be like, I'll pay for your college, get,
get a legitimate degree where there's actual job outlook at the end.
Like I'm not paying you to find yourself. When did you quit the job?
Like 2010 2010 2009 so right when you came to this store,
right around. So some things happened.
Like I was working at Boeing for three and a half years and I would just work by
day and I would drive.
I would drive up to Hollywood and like the Valley by night I was burning the
candle at both ends. Oh, you must have been tired all the time. I was,
well especially at first cause I didn't know the lay of the comedy land.
I was just going,
I thought everything was worth my time or you don't know until you do it.
So I would do some really shitty open Mike drive all the banner shows that were,
that wasn't a thing. That wasn't a thing yet as of late.
You know what's so funny is like the progression of the AllSeen is that first it
was in weird spots like a washing or to get laundromat and then it was like
meltdown and then living rooms were a big thing.
Living Room shows and then backyards were hot. [inaudible] the next shows,
oh yeah I want to do is get people in the living room where it's like the
hottest art show. It's called crawl space. Well,
let me make the ones just on their belly.
You do really funny one-on-one sketches that you do.
Like you play more than one role. Oh thanks man. On your Instagram,
like super bored during the day and you're like, no,
he's wanting to ask a why I do them and stuff. Yeah. All right.
So it's almost just some of the stuff I do is just a byproduct of,
I don't know, being creatively backlogged. So I love standup and I love sketch.
Those come to me naturally. Sometimes people will be like,
do you have a movie script? Or like a, you know, what's, what's,
what's your sit-com and that's just more work.
There's a scaffolding there that if I was teamed up with someone who understands
that world, maybe you'd be a little more easy.
But I don't want to Bang my head against a wall to understand a format where
standup and sketch just like come to me. Right. So that's why I lean into that.
So stand up has been a thing I've been doing for like 17 years.
I feel like I've developed, I'm good at that sketch. Um, I started doing,
I did it like I think h I was, I grew up through it. Like thumb,
I would do funny videos in school,
like video productions back in the day when you had two VCRs,
this is before like avid, so you'd like jog shuttle,
you would have two tapes you're mixing on tape and your raw tape.
So you would actually like make sketches on a VHS cassette.
So I was always into that cause I love that to know, you know,
so and then you know, you stopped doing it.
I'm doing stand up and then I moved to La and I'm not getting on stage that much
because it's so saturated here. It's so sad.
It's the biggest market here in New York,
although I think it's easier to get on stage as a standup in New York here you
have to deal with actors and there's a real bottleneck.
So I wasn't getting up a lot, but I'm a creative guy.
I have all these ideas and I had this idea for this video,
I'm like, how to attend an Afghan wedding or whatever. So, and I was gonna,
I was trying to get people to help me out and shoot it.
And then you're a run to, no one really gives a fuck.
Like if you can't do anything for anybody when you first come out here,
it's just sort of like, and not in a mean way,
it's just the nature of the wilderness. Like why am I going to,
you're not a proven thing. There's really no upside. So you get a lot of like,
yeah, I'll help you. And then flake.
So I rewrote it to just do it all in my apartment. So I just filmed this video,
this youtube video. It wasn't even on youtube yet though. It was, um,
I did this video called how to attend an Afghan wedding or something,
which is called African wedding. I put her on my space and it kind of does,
well, it kind of takes off a little bit. And then my brother was like, oh,
you should put it on youtube.
Like it wasn't ubiquitous to put stuff on youtube yet. I was like, Oh yeah,
okay. I'll put it on youtube to put on Youtube.
It kind of makes the rounds on there too.
And that was just kind of like the nudge I needed. Like oh I'm good at,
I could do this and I could do this while I'm waiting to get stage time.
So this was another avenue for me. I do stand up and then I do sketches.
And this was in the heyday of youtube when there was an appetite for youtube
sketch, like Indie, youtube sketch, just funny guys.
And there's just different sketch groups and everything.
I don't think there's an appetite for that now. Not Anymore. No. Why not?
It's become bite-size.
No one wants to watch sketch on like standalone people wanna watch makeup blogs.
They want to watch pranks, you know? I know cause like, you know,
cause I've uploaded, you see the downturn. There was a time,
is it because now it's Instagram, it's everything's more bite sized. So,
so I'm a sketch.
I love fully formed sketch and really taking my time like and me and my buddy
Aristotle, like a, he's really talented filmmaker and director.
I think I had just left Boeing and I had this idea for this American history x
type sketch has dominoes,
it's called dominoes and he and I did it and we put it out there and it was
beautiful. Like it's just one of my favorite sketches we've done.
And so I just kept on doing sketch and there was an appetite for it and then it
started to drop off. Like there wasn't a lot of viewership.
Now Youtube sketch will only work if it was on TV the night before.
Like if it's a key and Peele sketch that made it look like inside Amy or like a
tonight show sketch or the only way it'll make the rounds is if the sketch was
on TV and then has the potential to do on the Internet.
Just a a born and bred sketch on the internet doesn't take off anymore.
Instagram does.
So I just have all these ideas and I always write them down on my phone and
Instagram. Those,
like little one-on-ones is a way to get those ideas out in a very not precious
way. And it's just idea driven and people respond to it, you know?
So it's just more of like, Oh, let me get this idea out of my head.
So when you write,
do you sit down and force yourself in front of a notepad or a computer?
Back in the day, like when I was first doing stand up, I had two methods.
I would,
I would have the jokes that would just come to me and then I would like sit down
and try to manufacture jokes, you know, like, all right. All right Brian,
let's funny what's funny about the world. And I would come up with some stuff,
but I always found the things that always worked the best where the stuff that
just like came out of the ether, that just came to me.
And then eventually I got to the point where enough I would get enough of those
ideas, right. Didn't have to sit down and write.
So all I had to do was just be good about capturing what I'm receiving.
So I have my phone with me all the time.
Back in the day I had a marble notebook and all that,
but like phones have advanced so much I've ever known. We do. Yeah.
So whenever I get an idea, regardless of what the proper medium for it is,
I'll get it. I'll get an Instagram video idea, I'll get a fully,
fully formed sketch idea where I need like production value,
a sitcom idea or a standup idea.
I have different notes for each of them and I've just trained myself.
My brain is wired a certain way where I just catch the butterflies or just put
the bucket under the faucet. You don't sit down? No, I just, I'll get the idea.
I'll jot down as many words as I need to capture it. Maybe, I don't know.
Say something happens we go to, I don't know. I don't know.
We go to the lake or something and then like I get where we go hunting.
I get three ideas about hunting this many words to capture this,
not this many words. The catcher like separate in the commas.
So I have it be record your sets. Yeah, I'll record them.
Do listen to the recordings. I do. Well, it depends.
Like if I'm doing it hot night at the store,
that's kind of like the hits and I'm not going to learn a lot from the hits.
Right. When I want to work on stuff, I'll tell Adam at the store, I'll, I'll,
when I call in my veils, I go with late on Tuesday or Wednesday,
whichever one I get. I specifically asked to go late so that there's hardly,
yeah, there's no pressure. There's like 10 people trying to sober up.
I'm on my phone and it's not like this because they went to packed orr.
It's kind of like a, what do you guys like? I paid this much money,
I got a hot date with me, blah, blah, blah. It's a different show.
Joey Diaz started getting angry about it.
About what you can't proud. Well, you can.
You just have to choose different time slots or choose different shows to do it
on. There's new material nights. I love those.
Like Neil Brennan has one at west side. That's one of my favorite shows to do.
JF Harris has one. So you have those new material shows, but I'll just,
if you choose to do a later time slot,
it might be different for you because you're such a draw,
but [inaudible] nobody, you know, like I'm a cusper right now,
so I can just do late night.
But I just think you just sandwich those new bits in between obits you can,
but if you just want the total mental freedom of just like throw spaghetti
against the wall and not end in a professional way. Cause if, uh,
if I'm doing like a hot show and I'm trying to do a sandwich,
it can still put the brakes a little bit. Oh yeah. And you know,
I don't need that. I'm not Joe Rogan yet. Yeah. But that's,
that's where it's at. That's where it's at. I mean,
I find my way out of it by putting, when it hits the brakes,
you panic and then you find a way out.
And sometimes that's where you find a punchline sometimes.
Not sure to deal with.
The five out of ten five at a 10 are gonna eat shit out of 10 it's almost like
being a baseball manager. I have my, a string, my bs string.
So if I'm doing like a hot show and I wanna work on a beat,
so there's different levels of bits that I can Polish.
I'm not gonna throw a d a d in there. It's the prime time baby now. Right.
D is for 1:00 AM 1:40 AM D's got no pressure.
He's got a lot of potential. Did you Jeremiah show? I love that show. Yeah.
Doing that tonight, dude. I'll just fast.
I love shows where the audience knows the expectation is like you're a fly on
the wall in the process.
So it was less about prerecorded or preplanned material. Yeah.
There's so much goodwill. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Cause you don't get that one.
It's just like a show show.
I've come up with four or five legitimate bits that have wound up on specials
because Jeremiah show, yeah,
it's almost like a let's go stand up float tank. Yeah.
It's a great little quick shot. All right. What's, what's this idea?
What's that? And it's also because everybody knows that you're doing that.
So it's kind of more fun. And also if you hit a dead end, that's funny, right?
Because they know they know the theme of the show.
So let's wish you would do it more often. He's only doing it like once a month,
dude. Once a week, man. I Dunno. Maybe they know their,
what their sweet spot is. I don't think they do.
I think the sweet spots once a week. Yeah.
It's totally possible to do that show once a week. Yeah. Yeah.
I love those shows. When was the first time your parents saw you on stage? Um,
Oh, you know what? This is so funny. This is kind of,
so this is like the last bit on my special.
I talk about it like they see me once, once ever. Yeah. Really? Yeah.
Did you bomb? Oh yeah. Oh, in the worst. In the biggest way. Oh my God.
Oh yeah. I mean, do you want to hear the story? Fuck yeah, you do. Okay.
So this is just a rehash of like the last thing. So the last thing I said,
I closed my special with this.
So I'm like 17 I'm like 17 or 18 I'm at college,
there's a bulletin board and it says like Apollo amateur night on tour,
right? So there's a flyer,
like the Apollo is going on tour and you can audition.
And I have the Apollo Theater and at the Apollo theater. Yeah.
So they're going to all these major cities. Right. So I'm like, interesting.
Especially I'm just getting maybe a year in or a few months into stand up.
Like this is gonna be a great opportunity. Isn't it funny?
We loved the level of delusion you have as a young comic. Yeah. We like,
I'm ready. Yeah. They gotta hear what I got to say.
I've been doing this for a few months, so I take the, you know,
take the little tab. I have it, I get all the info. I go there, it's in Seattle.
So I go there to audition. I forget where they're holding the audition.
It's this like theater or whatever. So I'm sitting,
there's 342 people just like, wait, it's like American idol pretty much.
And there's like a bunch of like older black ladies singing.
I believe I can fly under their breath. I'm like,
just cause they're mostly singers, so you just hear like,
hey man [inaudible]
and I'm just standing there like, we didn't do my jokes later. Oh my.
Everyone's like, go ray mean. So finally it's my time to go. So I go out there,
I do my standup set and it does well. Like it does genuinely, well,
it wasn't like a, let's feed them to the sharks like I did well,
like I made them laugh, you know? So I find out, I get selected,
I think I'm one of 11 one of 11 who gets selected, some like sweet.
And then I invite everyone. I'm like, mom, dad, everyone from school and shit.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Everyone. It's that. It's at the paramount theater in Seattle.
Have you been there? Yeah. What does that 4,000 it's a big place.
Four thousand five thousand people, something like that. Maybe 3000 whatever.
It's in the thousands people, big place. It's one of our nicest theaters.
Beautiful. Yeah. So I laid everywhere
and then, oh, it's packed. Oh, oh my God.
So, so I do the dress rehearsal, I did the dress rehearsal, blah, blah.
Go through the motions. Lady comes up to me, she's like a producer.
That's great.
The producer of the show thinks like you should do this bit before instead of
your hip hop stuff, like do this bit first.
And it was like a this bit why he's about being Afghan or something, you know?
So I'm like, okay, whatever. Like I'm so new, I just trust the producer.
I'm like, I guess they know.
So I rearranged my set just based on the producers request, come to the show,
everyone's there, blah, blah, blah. It's my time to like,
they introduced me a little blah, blah, blah, you know,
please welcome the humanware. I'd come out and I'm like, hey guys. I'm like,
man, my name is [inaudible].
It's like an Afghan name or like Middle Eastern and Afghan to be exactly what.
He's like, Woo, Woo. I'm out that for maybe 20 seconds. They just started boom,
boom, boom. It's such an interesting sensation to be booed by them many people.
So just like it starts cascading like boom, boom, boom. And I've seen Apollo,
I know how it works. And you hear that like the
[inaudible]
Oh, I'm like, all right, I don't, I don't need to get swept off.
Like I know how this works. So I get booed off. Not The boot off,
just from talking about being a half can. Maybe, I don't know,
maybe it just really sucked. Maybe it was,
cause it was like close to nine 11 and they talked about being Afghan. Whatever.
I get, I get boot, you know, I mean, I'm sure it sucked balls too.
Whatever I was about to say I was gonna like be so bad.
So I was gonna get booed regardless, but I lasted maybe 15 seconds,
1520 seconds. So I'm just like shell shocked and then I'm just chilling.
In the hallway there was, there was a desk, there was like a s, you know,
like an old school student desk where it's like L-shape and they have the
basket. It's just in the stairwell for some reason. So I just sit,
I just sit in that chair.
I felt like I was in a video game or something cause that's not a human
experience really, that many people get to go through.
So I'm just trying to make sense of what happened and the world and my wife
moving forward. It's a lot going on. It's a lot going on. You know.
And then you know, I get up again at myself, I go up the stairwell,
I get my things from, you know,
I have to see everyone else and the great the worst.
See everyone in the green room area get my shit.
I get my car and I think I like drive home. My parents, I take a separate car,
right? And then I hear the rest of the story from my brother.
So they're all in the Dodge Caravan. My cousin Nilo, my brother, my dad,
my mom is just silent on the car ride home.
Like no one's talking cause I mean, you know,
they saw what they saw so no one's saying anything. And then obviously my dad,
my dad's like with number thrilled about me doing standup to begin with. Right.
So he, he breaks the silence. He goes, well,
there is no business like show business
[inaudible]
oh right. Like I think that's why when I want them to out, I want it to be like
such a polar opposite experience. And obviously I've come a long way from then,
but I'm almost grateful that it did happen because you know when comics trade
bomb stories, I fucking win every time. And to me,
for me to be so young like 17 and come back from that,
that means like there's really something like a fire in me or like I was meant
to do this or I really love stand up cause that's not a pleasurable experience
to potentially think that could happen again. You know?
Now they've seen you on television. Did they watch us? They seen me. Yeah.
I think you're special was good. Yeah, I think so.
I never know like my mom will tell me, but I never know what my dad catches.
And what was the last time you worked in Seattle? Um,
I'm trying to do the parlor [inaudible] go under like few months ago,
I think. Fucking a, yeah. So the pool hall part's gone to think so. Fuck yeah.
You like to play there? Yeah. It was a great gig. Play Pool and Oh yeah,
that's your jam. Oh my God. It's like you designed the club.
That's how I design a club. [inaudible] yeah. Yeah. So it's weird. I mean,
I could have them come out to another show they have there now. What's the club?
I don't know. I think it's mostly Thi Ah, no, they have um,
giggles or whatever in the university district or maybe it's called laughs.
It's called laughs. It's where giggles used to be.
So they'll have like one comedy club and all of this. The comma,
they have Tacoma, you know, that's crazy. People can, but these aren't Seattle.
Fuck man. Seattle used to be a scene. Got fucking parlor.
Live was a great club. How did it go under? Yeah, probably Brian Callan.
No, just grow it. What does that be kicked through?
It's the man who broke the parlor. Fucking ruined it, bro. Yeah. Yeah.
So when your parents come to see you,
will they come to see you in la or they come to see you? I haven't,
you haven't decided I've put it on the back burner for, I mean,
I guess if I do the tonight show,
I mean I've been to late nights already 20 years later, you know,
they gotta come see you live. I, yeah. Yeah. What should I do? I don't know.
Invite them to a show. Yeah. I don't know what show.
Pretend they're at the first show and then bring them to the second show. Yeah.
Just to mentally prepare. Yeah. You're obviously,
you have a little bit of a block, you're thinking about it. Yeah. Not a block,
but it's a, it's a thing. Oh, for sure. Yeah. If they saw you eat shit. Yeah.
And especially when they were so anti that and then,
but you were right and they were wrong. This is how it works. I mean,
my parents never yelled at me that I can do comedy or I was wasting my life or
that I'd be there with pimps and prostitutes. I mean, I love my parents.
We have a great relationship. This was just kind of like one,
one thing that was incongruent in the relationship.
No parents think their child is going to make it as a community.
It is the most.
Is the most impossible to imagine success business that you could ever think
your kid's going to go into? No, there's no,
like we were talking about w stand up that none of this is written down.
I'm talking about the principles stand up. There's no course you can take.
It doesn't exist. Any classes usually taken someone who's not
very successful at stand up for the most part. Yeah.
I don't know of any successful it can get. Chris Rock's not out there
teaching common class. I can give you the confidence to like jump off the cliff.
Yes. But outside of that you're not going to learn.
But, but here's the thing. All these principles that were taught,
I mean think about, look,
comedy is obviously a viable art form in a large scale venue.
I mean I just got done doing two arenas this weekend, right?
So we're talking about something that is right up there with music or even with
sports. I mean it's large scale, enormous people.
Yet there's no real like pathway that's written down.
There's no real principles of it that are universally assumed by all people who
participate in the art form. Whereas almost like if you learn music,
you learn chords and chord progression. You learn,
you learn how to use your diaphragm,
you learn how to sing and learn how to play instruments,
and you learn how to make a chorus and there's none of that for us.
I think it was just such a foreign,
I can understand where they're coming from cause it's such a foreign concept.
If you get an engineering degree or you're a doctor, you do a B, you get C,
there is a blueprint for it. Yeah. Stand up is just so nebulous.
Or just like the arts in general is just sort of like,
you can't tell someone what your path to success is going to be different than
Ian's path to mine. Sure.
And you kind of learned that as a comic as well early on because I think there's
a little bit of imposter syndrome like, oh, like somebody else gets something.
You feel like it's an attack on you, but you do it long enough,
you realize like, oh, everyone's journey is so different.
We're not in a hippy dippy way. Yeah.
But like your relationships are different than mine that are different,
so everyone hits at different times and it's not right or wrong.
It's just life and nature, you know? Yeah. You're,
you're different than everybody else.
You just got to concentrate on doing your best and figure out what you can learn
from other people's success and failures.
But don't think of it as your own success or failure. Yeah.
And eyes on your own paper. Yeah.
I wouldn't want my kids to do comedy if my kids would be hilariously
hypocritical if one of my kids was like, I want to be a comedian. I'm like,
listen, you're not gonna be a fucking comedian. Stop. Yeah.
I think where I differ with me and my parents is if they want to do something in
the arts, I'd be like, have at it. Like I support you. I want it to work out.
Yeah. But kind of have a foundation work on that.
I don't want to send you to do communications for four years. Yeah.
Like there's no school for it. Yeah. Stand up school. Here's the school.
Have a shitty childhood. That's the best school. I hadn't had a shot. Yeah,
I was well adjusted. I like that. Maybe that's why it hurt so much.
Maybe like I gave him everything. He still did it. Yeah. That's funny.
You might be one of the rare guys that didn't ever see new [inaudible] where
there's people obviously is what? Just well adjusted. Yeah.
I Dunno those Pete Holmes. I go even level headed. What about the Nichole? Him?
Well, I don't know. We've got the fuck out of here.
Everyone is fucked up to some degree. Yes. Yeah.
So that's why they're comics. Sure. Yeah.
But no matter who, anybody who pluck off of earth stuffed up. Yeah. Yes.
So this is a universal truth, but usually some kind of fucked up.
Childhood is a prerequisite. It helps. It's like the whole fuel.
It's fuel. It's like there's fighters that come from good childhoods to,
you know, I would have this, it's a dumb thought,
but I would have it as a kid trying to do stand up and not have to face this
wall of, I don't know, you know, my parents not wanting me to do it.
I'm like Oh man, I kind of wish I had like a,
like a worst childhood or like not middle-class. Cause then it wouldn't,
it wouldn't be questioned. It would just be like, yeah, of course.
What else going gonna do?
Well I was really healthy when I was young because I was a martial artist on
competing all the time and always worked out. And I always thought, man,
if I was a drug addict I'd probably be funnier.
I really used to think that way cause like the guys who did drugs at Kennison
and prior they had drug problems. Yeah. So fun. Like, Oh,
I mean you've been doing it for a long time so maybe you have a better
perspective on this.
I think like back in the day with the doing drugs and all of that part of that,
did that help? Like was it imaged?
Like how in terms of just seeing the comedy for what it is,
was it part it being new rock star stuff, drugs.
So you didn't have to be as tight as say like nowadays cause there's so many
more comedians or no,
it still is tiny wildness to it. There's wildness to it.
Like I think the funniest guy of all times. Joey d is a,
and w one of the reasons why he's the funniest guy of all time is the wildness.
Like he's truly wild. Like, and he knows the guys I'm watching him like in the,
or especially in 2019
the climate or in a, he don't, you can't tell. He doesn't know.
So he came out of a time machine. He's like Encino man.
I just thought him out and they just threw among the OLR people.
They're horrified and so happy. At the same time.
I think even the locus people when they're watching Joey and there's just this
energy and people are laughing so hard,
like you're all truism can't break through that.
You can't deny what's happening right now. So it kind of makes you,
I guess reassess what you're supposed. Like I shouldn't be laughing at this.
It's, it's a weird time for comedy,
but in that weird time you're going to get some of the best stuff because it's
like supercharged and it's like as it was it when it does get through,
if you can cover all the bases and make your arguments soundly and logically and
also have it be funny, I'll see Birdie that all the time too.
And like Joey's is such a force of nature. Yeah. It's,
you don't have time to like think about it as well or is this knee-jerk years
rolling burr?
We'll kind of just like throw out this crazy premise that no one,
no sane person would be on board. Like especially guys on dates.
Well you just hear, you know some, some of these arguments or whatever. Yeah.
He'll just throw it out there and he won't steamroll over it.
He'll just let it simmer. And that's my favorite. Yeah.
Cause like he's methodically,
surgically taking his time to proving the point of this argument.
Well a lot of these arguments I would suspect that he's having at home with his
wife, his wife, Sharon, powerful woman, and she's a feminist.
I mean what a cool woman too. You know what I mean? Just like, yeah.
So he has to formulate really well thought out arguments,
I would imagine. I mean maybe he would, but he, you know,
he's obviously thinking these through and like this is not, it's not,
he's not flippant about these points of view and his perspectives. Yeah.
So I just like how you just throw it like a piece of Bologna on the kitchen are
called windows nails. When he, when he nails it, man,
it's like so much more satisfying even then in the past because it's like
you're, you're,
you're making your way through the rockiest stretch of the river.
And I think those are the most rewarding bits as comedians.
The longer you've been doing it. Like,
I can be silly and get a joke and sure that's fun. But it's,
it's not that rewarding as if you have an argument like burger or something
where it's just countered counter-culture and you can methodically,
it's like going through the the laser field that's way more rewarding than just
walking down the hallway like mission impossible and all those lasers are
protecting the diamond limbo through these, what kind of movie is that?
He just walks up. Has An apple and goals. Right, exactly. And then the credits,
yeah it's a, it's an interesting time to get these ideas out there.
But you see by the reaction at the comedy store,
the people are looking forward to it because I think they feel the same way.
Like God damn,
everything's going so far and so many people are so god damn sensitive about so
many different things. It's not about intent.
They're just looking at magic words and buzz words and topics that are off
limits. There's no such thing as context anymore or intention. Yeah.
And you get that at the comedy store and I think it's the last place people are
talking this freely. Cause I used to think all right,
we've been in a little bit of a resurgence with stand up and like all the
specials and all that. I'm like, when's it going to burst? I'm like, Oh cool,
I'm going to get to miss two comedy bubbles. Sweet.
But then yeah, but then it's proven wrong. Like it's getting bigger and bigger.
Yeah, it's good. Yeah. That's why it was a bubble when it sucked.
Let me tell you about the bubble of the 1980s there was a bunch of people that
had our kind of way of talking about things.
So I got a cat in my room and the mouse was like wild kingdom and my house
was a way of conquering.
It was a comedy way of talking that these guys did.
There was some guys that just were not insightful and they just did comedy in a
way that they had heard people do comedy.
So they kind of just like mimic the sounds.
It's like you ever heard a band that sounds exactly like maybe stone temple
pilots or something like that, but they're not really like their clothes.
But like what's so weird is do you remember how much like soapstone brand,
I don't know if you remember it. Gorilla black? No.
What's that sounded exactly like notorious vig. No. Well yeah.
Fuck is that the real of black? Yeah. Really. Like when I heard it I'm like,
are we doing this? This is so crazy. It was insane.
Yeah. I watched a comic one night, um,
at in 1993 or something like that on stage in Montreal at just for laughs and he
was basically doing a Richard Pryor impression and I was like,
what in the fuck am I seeing? It's like this guy was doing prior,
I mean everything about his set he was doing prior. I'm like,
this is so strange to see that people do that well,
that that was a part of the bubble in the bubble.
There was these guys who would wear the clothes they thought a comedian would
wear and say the things and there was so much work and there was so many,
there was so many clubs and there was so many a evening at the Improv's and all
these different little show, anyone to get a piece,
people got t mimic the part two.
There was a lot of people back then that were arrogant,
that were working and they were headliners and they were arrogant and they were
fucking terrible.
And I really enjoyed watching them fall off the face of the earth. You know,
I'll tell you some names afterwards,
but the other names I was going to tell you, yeah, but these,
these people were doing comedy in a UN.
They weren't participating in an art form. They were mimicking.
They were mimicking the people that were participating in the online forum,
like love him or hate him. Cherry Seinfeld's and artist. Oh, I love Seinfeld.
Yeah, I do too. But he's an artist. His style, whether you,
I've heard criticisms that he's not deep enough.
He doesn't talk about sex or anything dangerous, whatever he likes.
What he likes. He likes to talk about stuff.
He likes a certain style of comedy and he's as a master at that style,
but he's spawned so many babies with Teresa.
Nia would call babies like Patrice on neo like would say a a like a, hey man,
you got a lot of babies out there.
There's a lot of people that are imitating you, you've got babies.
Then there was a lot of like David tell the perfect this shitload of babies.
There's a lot of, [inaudible] had a lot of babies. Yeah.
Dane had a Mitch Hedberg.
I remember Mitch had a lot of [inaudible] see a ton of babies. Yeah,
there's a few people that mimic,
but during the eighties it was,
there was a few innovative people and a lot of babies.
It was like there was 10 babies to everyone innovator and you had these like
fake headliners and they would show up in town,
but they had those premises that everybody had.
They had those beats that everybody had. They talked in the same way.
They didn't take any chances.
They were shooting straight down in the middle and that was the bubble and that
all went away. That all went away. And when that went away,
those guys died off and there was people that were left over,
the people that were left over where the actual comics that actual people were
good enough where people would repeatedly go to see them at clubs.
They wrote a lot. They, they practice. They were,
they were interested in the actual art form itself.
And I was really fortunate that I started out in Boston or Boston had a very
high standard due to Barry Crimmins really in protect document. It was great.
He's a brilliant, he was brilliant guy arrested piece Barry. Um,
I loved that guy, but he, that guy, he was one of those guys when,
when he was nice to me as I got older and you know,
I was terrified of him. Terrified of him,
like him seeing me when I saw it really meant so much. Well,
I knew what a high standard he had for comedy and he was one of the main reasons
why there was no hacks that were tolerated in Boston and that, that you want,
everybody had to be original,
everybody had to do good material and everybody sort of policed each other,
you know? And when, um,
when you have a community like that, you,
you get to see the art form flourish in a, in a very good way. And we,
we had a lot of like different people,
they were different but they were all like really high level.
So we would get these guys that would come in from out of town road,
guys that were babies,
there were Seinfeld babies are different and you would see how poor they looked
when they were surrounded by these original murderers.
So you'd have like guys like Steve Sweeney and Lenny Clarke would go on stage
and then one of these babies would go up after him and just eat blights of shit.
Why are they going after?
They had a terrible system in Boston that was really mean and it was designed to
make new, designed to make national headliners bomb. I really,
yes, yes.
They would pay them a lot of money to book them at a club and they would book
them on a show with three local headliners and these local headliners would just
fucking straight up murder and they would do all this local Boston stuff that
made everybody excited.
And then they would have one of these guys who was used to going to Cleveland.
Hey, I was just in Indianapolis, had a great time, uh, did a little comedy.
That's what I do. I'm a comedian.
And they would go up there and just eat plates of Shit and get booed off the
stage. And people would leave. And they were,
they would do it on purpose just to teach them a lesson or something? No,
they were just mean like those guys never. First of all those comments,
those comics never left Boston. Okay.
And they would murder almost every night and they were all animals.
They're doing coke and they were drinking. They were fucking savages.
They'd pay them and coke like no bullshit. Yeah. Nick's comedy.
Stop used to pay people in coke. Yes. It didn't pay me in coke.
I never did go right. But I knew of the whole deal. Everybody knew the deal.
And so when these guys would come in from out of town,
they would be angry at these guys. And they're like, who is this fucking guy?
He's got evening at the Improv. I don't have that show.
He was on a fucking movie with Billy Crystal Fuck Camp.
And they would go on in front of those guys and light them on fire.
Light them on fire. Who's dictating this at the club club
comics club? They're all, oh, so one's on coke. So this is fun for them.
That was just fun. And they would,
they would do it on purpose and then a cool you would,
but some guys would survive. Like I saw Don, my rare in that environment,
but dom murdered, there was a thing dom murdered.
So he would go there and he would talk about how strong the lineup was.
You know, as I just amazing. This is great.
But he would go up a murder because he was a real comic.
So dom was there pre bubble during the bubble post bubble.
He's a comic. I mean those are the best guys.
Funny guys who take funny guys on the road with them. Yes.
Because not everyone does that. But yeah, you know like a panic. They want,
they want like the best comics.
They're like I want someone funny to Yes I want a great show.
You know the reason why I take Ian or Santina or I always took Joey Diaz before
he got too big. You know Joey Dee is selling out the Chicago theater.
He's fucking murdering it. But all those guys, Ori and Dunkin I there,
I want to have fun. I want to be with comics, I want,
I want this show to be great. I don't want to be the only one. That's funny.
That's gross. Right. And I think it's a way to discover new comics as well.
Cause like I was, I was opening for Neil for a bit for his tour,
for most of the dates and news is so fun for me because like all headline and
stuff,
but I'm not a draw yet so I need to have a walkup for whatever the club I'm
doing. Like they need to have the comedy on state's great, you know,
and Madison, Wisconsin, it's just, they have walk up,
they just have a trust with the community. They all just come to shows
or like comedy works in Denver. I've just done comedy on stage and I heard it.
That's great. That's really good. There's a theater right next door.
You probably be doing that. Like it's be talented in theater.
The last time I was there there's actually a poster for that theater in the
bathroom out here. So it's fun to do that when they have, um, a walkup audience.
Like the comedy works, like you said, comedy was in Denver.
They had some brand club. Like I'm not a draw yet, like in purgatory.
But the Neal thing was cool because they're all coming for Neal, their theaters.
I'm just doing 20 minutes, which is like a, like a shit that out. It's nothing,
you know, cause I'm like headlining. So there's no pressure.
They're there for Neil. I have a great set. And they're like, Yo,
you were funny. So you get like fans from his fans tables. It's the best.
And it's a great show as a, as a whole. Like we compliment each other. So yeah,
you get to interview and he gets to introduce you to a funny comment. Yeah.
And I'm so grateful that he gets to do that. Like pull a guy up and,
and sort of take a little credit for like, I dunno. Yeah, no, it's great.
That's where it's at, you know? But I don't think this bubble is popping.
It's too fun. It's too good. I mean, there's too many good people.
As long as the art form is good,
the bubble only exists in pops when it's a fake thing.
Like it's a Ponzi scheme. That's not really the case right now. Yeah.
There's so many good comedians. Right. And everybody's working hard. You know,
everybody realizes that there's a lot of pressure on you. So they're all like,
that's what you were saying, like how many sets I do.
That's why I do so many studies. Yeah. This is the only way to do it.
I do two sets a night, three sets a night all the time.
And there's so many outlets now too,
which is kind of what's helping it not pop is yes, you have Netflix,
you have these new streaming like a HBO Mannix on Amazon, Apple,
Apple Password on here in a couple of days and he's got his Amazon special.
Yeah. And so does, um, uh,
Alonzo Boden is Amazon specials coming out soon. And then, um,
there's a bunch of other people that have Amazon specialists.
I'm seeing people advertise them on their Instagram.
So Amazon is putting together a bunch of specials now,
which to me is very, very exciting because they have the marvelous Mrs Maizel.
Oh yeah. One of my favorite shows.
So I'm just psyched that there's a lot of new venues and then there's new
streaming things. Like who knows, maybe Hulu will get into stand up, you know,
what, maybe some of these other streaming services we'll get into. Stand up.
It's great for everybody, man. It really is. There's plenty.
Or there's guys like Andrew Schultz,
he just went straight to as a performer and as a comedian and I think everyone
has varying degrees of,
I think anx that he had coming up and I kind of felt that way as well.
Like people have varying degrees of how much the industry fucks with you.
Sometimes I feel and sometimes I don't, I don't feel in,
I do for certain things and,
and that was just really refreshing just to take the power back and even seeing
it happen with, I have so many peers in the game, like I've known Theo forever,
we've been puttering around town and doing shows and just, you know,
obscurity and then doing the podcast and,
and just seeing him take his own fan base and power back and everyone wanted to
fuck with him now and like they weren't, they weren't launching that guy.
You kind of learn to that. It's just monkeys picking stocks. Well,
a little fairness.
Theo turned a corner like two years ago where I remember watching him before and
it might, sky's kind of funny.
He's a unique but then two years ago me and Adam were in the back of the room.
I'm like this motherfuckers turned the corner. Like he was just killing it.
Yeah, he was just really funny but like a funny in a new way.
Like he had hit some [inaudible] some of the words he uses to describe as what
he hit that gear and then everything took off from there.
It was a lot of it was just hard work, persistence,
hard work and just eventually it really clicked.
I think it was like a one two punch.
I think it was turning that corner and then also just the word of the people
democratically,
just his podcast and and him doing other people's podcasts for sure.
Cause he's really good on podcasts. He's just fucking funny and silly and funny.
And then his own podcast where he just looks right at the camera and it rants
and talks about shit and you realize like how his fucking unusual brain words.
Funny.
Sometimes he's one week figure out what this algorithm is or what he's doing.
And you go, no, this is him. You ain't figured that out. Yeah. No,
you're never gonna figure that out. How would you think to call it that? Never,
yeah, he's got Theo comedy for sure,
but it's like we were talking about earlier where no one can really teach you
how to do comedy. Like you're, you gotta figure it out and no one,
no classically trained comedian, if there ever really was one,
wouldn't ever teach
terrible to classically trained comedian. It would be those babies. Yeah.
It would be like those guys that are like fake Seinfeld's or fake gaffigans or
whatever the fuck they are. It would, yeah,
the Shults thing was really cool to see because she just did it on his own. Yup.
And here's the thing, and I wanted to bring this up with you, Jamie,
is he shadow band on Instagram? Tell me what you think is going on.
Because I texted him when that happened because I looked it up. Yes.
And His name is shut up right at the top of my list.
But he said other people with me, it didn't show up.
A mind really changed the algorithm because I've noticed if few,
it could be what it could be,
but there you don't have to take it like a case by case scenario.
Was the person that first sent it to him, are they already following him?
Do they search his name a lot? Did they block anything he's ever done?
People have told him, hey man,
I'm having a hard time finding your Instagram page.
And so he asked me about it and I said, what do you mean? And I go, you,
I see you right now. You're on my feet. And he goes, no, no, no.
If you go to search me. So I was go, okay, let me search you. I go, whoa.
I searched Andrew Schultz, nothing.
I mean a bunch of other people but not him.
And he's got a lot of followers like go, let's do it right now. Pull it up,
put it up on screen. Okay, put it up on the screen.
Let's just do it in real time.
Let this part of what I was saying is I follow him stuff.
You're not already following me, right. My shop in a different way.
But I do follow him. I look at feet now just right Andrew.
Give them some space. Right. Space. I haven't got the inch space.
Well, you should have shown up. It should have shown up already,
but just space and then type in his name. See it's not coming up,
right. That's what I'm saying. Now, hit search.
I don't think you can't search on that. Oh, on the web. But look,
it's not showing up. You see Andrew Schulte's fans,
even when I typed in his actual account name, it didn't show up. Oh, pick up.
Hold on a second. What does that Andrew Schulz fans, what does that click on?
That right there below it. Blow. Blow, blow. Keep going. Keep going.
The blind count. There it is. That's right. Click on that. I know that it's not.
So it's his fans have made, oh, 165 followers. That's crazy.
Right? No, I know. It's not him. I'm just trying to figure out what it is.
So just in that search,
it's not showing up and it wouldn't show up for me on my phone either.
Now it doesn't make any sense because what does he have?
Like a half a million followers. How many followers does he have?
That is not interesting. Like he thinks he's being shadow banned.
What's the, are they trying to like get some money out of no,
28022802000 people.
And he can't find his page on Instagram. Does it Schultz with a t or no,
just no, no. U L Z.
But it's not showing up and it's not showing up on mine. Even now,
we might be being paranoid here and it might be just something in the search
algorithm that for whatever reason his thing isn't showing up. And the,
he used to say Hezie Schultz, I don't know why Hesi was that name.
Okay. And maybe he thought that Hesi was fucking them up.
So he took Hesi out of his name in the it on his Instagram page.
So it just says Andrew Schulte's now. But even though still you can't find it.
Yeah, that's weird. You have to type
Ben, Andrew shoulds all together with no space and then you'll find them.
That's what I just didn't, it didn't come up with no space.
That's what I was just doing in front while you were asking me to type stuff and
I was typing, so you did it with space and no space.
That's when I did it to him. I was like, if you, if you're typing and no space,
that's where the issue is. If I'd leave that note, if I typed in all the way,
it's showing up right away and he said, well,
I'm seeing that from people both ways. So I go off if that's what you're seeing,
then I'll go out on a limb and sort of say,
does your show on is manipulating that search result because you can manipulate
search results. Here's the thing. They do.
Shadow banned people on certain social media platforms is,
has been revealed through hidden camera conversations with people who are
whatever moderators or engineers or people that work behind the scenes on
Twitter or Facebook and they do manipulate algorithms,
manipulate searches and shadow ban people. And there's a lot of people,
particularly conservative people, which he's not conservative,
but what he is is, you know,
he's a Raunchy comedian and he might have done something that someone felt was
not woke or what have you.
And they want to slow down the broadcasting of a signal.
That's entirely possible. I don't know if it's true though.
I would love to have a, a logical explanation that is to lie.
He's not showing up. Yes. But he's, you know,
he's complaining about it that it's a shadow ban. Anyway, go follow Andrew.
Andrew Sholtz. Yeah. Uh,
S S H U l z. S. H. U. L. Z.
Go follow the trail just to tell Instagram shadow bands that we can get around
you. Bitch. He's a marketing genius. It's just great to hear him talk about,
you know, what he's doing and how to get around it. And it's exciting cause you,
you forget as an artist that you have a lot of power. Like you're everything,
you're, you're the product. And sometimes, uh, especially in the old models,
you just kind of waited to be anointed. Well,
he's got millions and millions of views on his special on youtube.
And if you stop and think about if that was on comedy central,
which comedy central didn't want to give him a special, um,
he probably would get like maybe a million people would watch it when it came
out and that would be the end of it. I have a special,
and I don't think people are watching it, just youtube is accessible.
It can be in comedy jail. You could do a great special and no one can find it.
Yeah, yeah. Everyone has youtube. Everyone can click on a link.
Everyone has youtube. And this was his logic. He was like, you know what,
I'm just going to release the whole thing on youtube and look,
he went straight from not selling out clubs to selling out theaters like that
and now he sells out everywhere internationally.
And it's amazing from afar to watch the industry change.
[inaudible] yes. He's realized,
cause I think early on you so much of your self worth is,
is put in these people and you just, you, you don't realize till later that, oh,
they're just heat seeking missiles. Yup. Yeah. They don't, you know,
majority of them don't have tastes, tastes. It's just whatever's happening.
Whatever's hot, can I get a pie of whatever this is? I mean, including hacks.
I mean there, there's a long history of them supporting hacks and thieves.
It's just a thing where they're, what they're trying to do is make money.
You know, if you're an agent or a producer,
I mean there's no benefit in you supporting an artist that is not going to be
commercially viable. Yeah. You have to find out like, who,
who's it gonna who's going to pop? Who's going to be the next movie star?
Who's gonna be in the movies? You know, you have to figure that person out.
And what was it like when, uh, you know, limits, see a thing went down.
What was the climate like for you, say professionally after that went down?
Because he was at a different level at that time, right? Yeah.
Who's more popular than me with comedy? For sure. You know,
I was doing fear factor back then and I wasn't really working on the road that
much. I really couldn't, you know, I was doing
no 30 episodes a year plus, so 30 weeks, a year of work.
And I wasn't really enthusiastic about traveling when I was doing that.
I just wanted to, I was exhausted. Um, and then I was doing the store too,
so it was mostly just working on my act and just doing standup. And um,
they supported him because he was the one who was making the money. I mean,
in fact, I left my agency because they wanted me to apologize to him.
And then Louie wound up leaving them and a towel wound up leaving them and
Swartz and wound up leaving them.
Everybody left him right after that because they found out that they wanted me
to apologize to them, to everybody in the industry knew what was going on,
but they wanted to turn a blind eye and make money. So it did,
it hurt my career while I stopped going to the store.
But that didn't hurt me as much as it hurt them.
It hurt the store cause I told everybody. And then that place was a ghost town.
I mean it went from being packed when I was there cause I would let them put my
name up on the market and I was working for free.
That's how fucking stupid Tommy was fucking dummy.
But then when you know, he got fired and I came back and made it all worth it.
You know, the whole thing was,
it was interesting because it could show you that if there was someone who was
doing what Mincy was doing, that you can get away with it.
And even with someone who was successful like me,
like I got another agent like that. I mean, but,
but I let my agent literally said I was going to have to apologize to him.
I'm like, you're out of your fucking mind. I go, listen,
I'm not only am I not doing this, this, we're never going to work this out.
I'll never work with you again because you're asking me to apologize to someone
who was literally a vampire,
someone who's stealing from the work of other artists.
It's all he does and you guys know it and you guys are profiting of this.
Like this is you're making a giant mistake. And I turned out it was correct.
But it was interesting because even though it didn't hurt me financially,
I got to see that they were trying to, cause you know, he wanted them,
he wanted an apology and I was like, you're out of your fucking mind.
I'm not apologizing to you. And as it kept getting,
people became more and more aware,
other people started finding other bits that he had,
like the real thing that sunk him was Cosby. Really funny.
Now when you think about it now,
but he had this like such obvious theft of a Cosby bit. I mean,
he still all the inflections and he switched it around a little bit,
but people who would work with him and trying to tell him to stop doing that bit
because there was a giant famous Cosby bit and he just insisted that he was
going to do it. And when that bit got on Youtube,
that and Mexican folks finding out he wasn't really Mexican,
that was a fucking knife in the heart when they were like, wow, like what?
When they found out what his real name was, they're like,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
There was so much going on then though that was, um, you know,
he was really popular.
He went from selling out these giant places and you know,
kicking ass all over the country and people knew him from the television show
and they thought he was hilarious.
I guess that's Kinda cool about stand up is that of all the art forms,
standup has the most justice and then now it does now.
But there's a lot of people made it through the net back in the day,
they were just criminals.
I guess it was harder to know back then there was no internet.
There was just sort of like word of mouth or you would hear stories.
We all know that there's parallel thinking and then there's even cases where you
forget you heard something. I've done it.
I've definitely hash it out like a comic or something and be like, for sure.
Okay, yeah, you can have it. Or we're all pals. Right. It's bound to happen.
It's going to happen. Just have the conversation. If you're a pro, you're like,
all right, I don't need that bit. Yeah, exactly.
And then there's also people that are like, you know, like you said that word,
and that's the word that I say in my bit. And you're like, what?
Like some people, some people are hypersensitive to it. Almost like delusional.
Yes. Yeah. Some people get delusional. That's,
I talk about being in a relationship, so, oh yeah. That, I appreciate it.
That's hilarious. With my girlfriend recently too, so yeah, I own that. Well,
especially things that are current events, right? It feels like something like,
I can't believe you're talking about Trump, you know? I do that whole trumpet.
Yeah, like what are you crazy? I've seen these conversations.
Yeah.
That guy's never gonna live that down. I'm telling you this is just brewing.
This is just starting. He's never living that down. That's one. You know,
I'll wreck your shit. I'll throw you down a flight of stairs.
Was there stairs nearby or would they have to go up?
They have to go find some stairs. You're not going to live like the trip down.
That's a weird thing to say to someone.
Throw you down a flight of stairs so you want to hurt them,
but you want the gravity to do all the work. Yeah, that's true.
So it's not that tough. Sleazy.
He has all that potential energy once it gets up there and just knock them over.
Right. That's funny. And you're looking at it. An engineer.
I've got to use it somehow. My Dad's so proud that I pulled that out of the bag.
Do Use your engineer training at all when your stand up? Is there anything else?
I think a one quality I can take away from all the engineering schooling,
like I'm not doing formulas and equations and all that,
but I think it's just a manner of which I approach things and time management,
I'm wired a certain way where I can be studious on my own. I don't,
I'm not like smoking weed on the couch and like I'm a muse or I'm a vessel.
God's man. Like I'm okay, what do I got?
What's what I want to do and one of my goals for this year, let's say,
or how many tests do I have when I'm working on for this set.
So I'm just a little industrious. It's taught me and also when it comes to bits,
like I see them in a certain way, like um, the way I get the bits,
it's very organic and that's what I like about it is that it's not clinical or
anything. It's just magical how I think of something and I'm grateful for that.
You give yourself time to think.
Do you like specifically do things like go on walks or anything where you,
you're not specifically,
but what I found is one of my favorite things to do is to go to a diner,
sit in a booth, a breakfast, have coffee, and they'd keep on refilling it.
And I'm on my phone and I'm on Twitter and Instagram and my mind's just kind of,
and I'm listening to music. I love music.
So I'm just scouring Spotify and hype machine just for new music hype machine.
I don't know what that is. Uh, so I love, so that's how I find music.
Like hype machine and also Spotify hype machine is this blog aggregate.
So there's music blogs, right?
There's one called like acid stag that I like a lot.
So you can follow a blog and they'll post songs every day.
Maybe they'll post six songs a day.
This website you can follow different blogs and it's like following someone on
Instagram or something.
So you look at your year feed and you get to hear all the songs your favorite
blogs have posted within the website. And there's an app on your phone too.
And these are kind of underground songs.
These aren't top 40 so it's a way to hear great music that you wouldn't hear on
the radio and they're, they're not in a less great,
there's this whole sub culture and genre of music that is magnificent,
but it's not on top 40, so people don't really know about it.
So height machines,
a great way to get some cool tracks off the beaten path and a spot.
I've never heard of that before. That's interesting. Height machine.
So music plays a big part with my comedy. Yeah. Machine.
What's popular now? How oversize. It's like their top 40.
So even this is a little poppy for me. Ah,
I'll have certain blogs and I like finding, yeah, it's when, yeah. Dove. Yeah.
I mean for this type of music. Yeah. Whatever it makes,
whatever it makes the popular land. Tay, hold on.
You're not going to scroll back up please. Duranti Maya, that's poppy.
Fuck knows any of this music. Childish Gambino. I know that guys,
if you're like a teen or early twenties, you'll, you'll know this stuff. Really?
Yeah. Um, so I just love listening to music.
Drinking coffee and on my phone and I'll just get these ideas.
But also just living life. I'll be walking around and I'll get an idea,
jot it down. Well you don't have a day job, which helps. No, that's,
that's really helps collect material, believe it or not. Yeah.
I think comics have to be amused and you have to be experiencing just life,
life if you're working all,
it's not like it was harder when I was working at Boeing cause I had that mental
fatigue of just working on parts and all that and computational stuff.
So I'm not thinking about bits when I'm them. Suck it out of you too.
I can see that because you think that, oh, it's just like, you know,
I didn't really work on my act that much during the day anyway.
Now I have a job doing, doing, acting.
I'll probably get just as much material [inaudible] no, no, you won't.
You're going to be wrapped up in whatever the fuck you're doing and then when
you go to do standup, you'd be like, Oh yeah, time to do stand up now.
I'll think about it. Yeah.
But you really need that time to be just three to think. Yeah.
It's kind of crucial to the creative process. I didn't think about that,
but that's true. Cause those other jobs you, you have mental focused,
you're not dedicating to standing bits, right. Yeah.
Where I'm at a diner and yeah, my mind is just floating around.
It seems like you're not working like someone on the outside. We'd be like,
you're not even working. I might come up with a gem.
That might be my next closing bit. Yeah, that is worth randomly. Yeah,
because you gave yourself that time. Yeah.
Like you just are watering the grass and a mushroom pops up. Even with me,
I think there was a big breakthrough in just accepting that I'm an artist
because you know,
my parents didn't want me to do it for so long and it was this dirty thing and
it was always pimps. Some process would go to the club,
so stand up and comedy was, I was like a vampire feeding.
It was just this thing that I do over here and I want to do it.
But it was always different than what I'm supposed to be doing.
It was always on the side. It's like a hobby type where I would,
there was a division within my mind,
but once I left Boeing and I was doing it full time, what was the impetus?
Like what, how'd you make the decision? Ideally?
I always had this pie in the sky scenario that would happen for me to leave
Boeing. I would think, all right,
if I got to the point where I'm doing engineering and stand up,
I want it to a point where it's glaringly obvious that engineering is holding me
back from this other path and I have to make the jump.
So I needed that to happen. And then I,
I think enough things happened where I kind of had that situation. I had,
I booked this acting thing, I booked a roll on Chuck NBCS, Chuck.
I was still working at Boeing. It was like this huge guest star.
I forgot about chuck. Yeah. So I, I,
and I would do these things towards the end of my tenure at Boeing, I would,
I had a manager and I would get auditions.
So I would duck out for lunch and I'm in Long Beach and I would drive up to
Hollywood and do an audition and I'd be gone for a,
that one I would like do a combo, let's say lunch and doctor's appointment.
Then I would do, or I would take off.
I would come in early and leave early if I had an audition,
but I had to be very strategic about what I did. I can't be from a day job.
So this one went out for chuck and then I auditioned and then it got it as this
huge guest star and I'm still working at Boeing and they need me for eight days.
I have a day job. So I said I had a family emergency in Seattle,
I have to go back home. And they're like, oh, okay.
But I'll just in Burbank shooting, chuck [inaudible] just shooting.
And then I go back to work and people see you on TV now.
Luckily there was enough of a lead time where that wasn't coming out for a long
time. So he quit. No, not yet. So I just thought like, okay, cool.
Like I still keep on,
I can keep on being an engineer and then a couple of things happen.
I use anybody notice you on chalk.
But the thing is that happened when I left Boeing. So,
so a aired after I had left. Oh, how much lead time was there?
Quite a quite a bit. Maybe like six months or it was towards the end. Um,
and so no one knew.
I did stand up and the beauty of it was when I entered the workforce of
engineering, everyone is substantially older than me.
They were like in 30s or they don't know about hype machine. Yeah,
they don't behind machine. And so it wasn't second nature to be like,
what's your mind space? Or, cause Jake would have been up immediately. Yeah.
So there was no, social media was not second nature with coworkers.
So there was a big enough generational gap. So I was able to for three years,
just no one know anything.
So I do the chuck thing and then I also,
I got really far in standard,
NBC has the stand up for diversity initiative every year. Um,
you do like a stand up competition thing from different cities and then they
have a final showcase. So I got like second on that.
So I got some college gigs out of it.
I got quite a few college gigs and then I booked this show on MTV called
disaster date, which is like boiling points for dating.
They had a cast and I was one of the cast members and you would just go on dates
with friends, would set up their friends with dates and they'd be like,
this is the things that she hates. And you would just be the worst date ever.
And you see how long they laughed on the date.
So they needed me for eight months or no, three months. Three fuck,
what do I do? Yeah, three months.
So this was kind of that situation where I'm like, fuck, all right.
I just did chuck. I have some college gigs lined up.
This MTV show needs me for three months. I got it. I got to do this.
Oh I didn't do that yet.
I tried to take a leave of absence cause I planned on coming back. I was like,
can I need something? Came up gonna be gone for three months and then I'll,
and they're like, no, you can't do that. And I'm like, um, are you sure?
I just kept on trying to finesse it and they wouldn't let me.
And then I was reading about unemployment and stuff and I read that you couldn't
quit. You had to get fired, right? Yeah. Yeah. So I'm like, alright, um,
here's what I'm gonna do. So I wrote my last day there,
I wrote an email just like, hey guys, I'll be gone for this three months.
I plan on returning on this day.
And then I just went incommunicado like I didn't,
I didn't pick up any phone calls if I was going to get fired.
I wanted to get fired by them cause I didn't want them,
I didn't want to go on the books that I quit. For some reason,
my engineering brain is like, this is great. I'll get them on a technicality.
They'll fire me and I'll get my unemployment if I need to. So I leave mowing.
I'm shooting the show for three months and then eventually I get like a
termination letter in the mail from Boeing. I'm like, yes, yes.
But then it turns out, I mean,
I could have collected unemployment from the MTV show,
so I didn't even have to go out that way. Oh really? I mean it was fine.
Like it wasn't, yeah, we used to collect unemployment for dude. He was,
he was like my guiding light in that regard. Cause early on,
especially when I left Boeing and the MTV thing comes and goes,
I do two seasons of it and then, but that's not like a fucking,
it's got like a rock solid thing and Ra would show me the ropes. He'd be like,
please collect unemployment from knocking job.
You're good enough to jump in and you're going to unemployment.
Let's hope it works. Yeah.
He taught me how to do it and I never heard of anybody getting unemployment from
acting gigs. Now we would do a commercial. That's how it works.
Just like an employees, you pay into it and all that. It's all on the up and up.
It's just part of an actor's I guess requirement or necessity of an actor is
being available. Yes. So if you book a commercial, like a Toyota commercial,
let's say you make 30 grand or 20 grand, whatever, in that chunk,
you've made enough money in that quarter tool to apply cause you're paying into
it. We just think, oh you have to hit a certain amount and then you're eligible.
There's tiers of how much money you get for unemployment,
then you're eligible for x amount of dollars every two weeks or whatever.
And that helped me keep a full for like a year.
And then I got to the point where I didn't need, I didn't need it.
I had enough steady work coming in. But that was,
when did you tell your parents?
I thought that they would take it worse than they did,
but I think we had been at odds for so long that what I've noticed is you can't
stay at an 11 your whole life. Right? Yeah.
So I think they had to know this day was going to come eventually cause I would
talk about it. That was the plan the whole time. I guess.
They just never thought that it would come to fruition. Now when you quit,
how long did you wait or when you get fired,
how long did you wait before you told them? Uh,
you don't have a day job anymore. It was, that was around Christmas.
It was around the holidays. So we were at my aunt's house and then I told,
I told them I was like, it went over better than I thought. Yeah. All surprised.
What did you say? All the good things you're getting. Yeah, obviously, come on,
I'm not gonna be like, I quit and I'm going to figure it out.
I'll figure it out. But I like having us for money later.
I'm really proud of that in this whole adventure.
I've never asked my parents for money and I think that's a win. Yes.
That's a huge win. That's a huge win. Yeah.
And I hope that they kind of notice that through the tough times.
I never that that means that's a sign. It's going well.
They should figure that out. That's a giant win. Yeah, but I mean,
I just want to tell people if they have the similar path that you don't,
there's this romanticized version of being an artist where you just pack up all
your things, come in and out of a yeah, man. Like, no,
I gotta be 100% of my art. Yeah, you have a plan.
Do you want to set yourself up for success or are you trying to draw you and
artists? Are you an engineer?
We both know there's a lot of hours in the day that you're a prime example
of that. It's amazing. All the things you do,
there are so many hours in a day and it's such a cop out to be like,
I'm going to be all in it. I'm going to live and breathe my art,
otherwise I'm going to be a hack. No, be methodical.
Set yourself up for success. Well, I think you have to be disciplined.
Discipline for sure. I think it's very important.
You can still be artistic and discipline. A contrary to popular opinion.
You can and you have to be careful not to lose yourself once you come to la.
How many people do you know who come out here with a particular plan to like be
an artist or a writer and they're fucking birthday parties every day?
Like when you come to La,
you can go to someone's birthday party at a bar every day. Oh yeah.
Yeah. There's so many. It's everyone's birthday every, every day to this town.
So big. Yeah, that's true. So you get sucked up into the party life.
You'll see it too. Some artists just get like,
they'll go down this networking rabbit hole and they have no tangible and they
never want to do a bad show.
They just want to do the best shows and they don't just focus on getting good at
stand up comedy. It's just, I'm going to this party,
So-and-so is here and they have nothing.
Do you ever envision a time where one of us or maybe a collection of us writes
down all these things?
What do you mean some sort of a guidebook to stand up comedy? I really think,
yeah, someone could benefit from it.
I mean this really is the only art form that, as we were saying before,
is a viable art form.
A large scale that doesn't have any book or nothing. Yeah.
Not, I mean every fucking book about comedy, like how to do comedies.
Terrible worst. Yeah. You know, it's weird. You know,
it's scary. There's all these formulas.
I think podcasting has taken some of the mistake out of it.
I think it's also created a bunch of fans of the process too. Sure.
Like I've talked to people that have like come up to me at the comedy store and
said, Hey, I saw you first do that bit a year ago,
and then I watched it change and then when it became on your Netflix specials,
like Holy Shit, like look at it.
It's kind of cool to see it grow and become viable. Yeah.
I think it's cool that there's an audience for that or that they value that
because I think it's easy to assume the end consumer just wants to see the
finished product, but their comedy fans are so savvy now.
They want to see that process and they feel like they're let in like a cool,
like it's not a magic trick anymore. No, no, no. It's different. Yeah. No,
I agree. Listen man. Uh, I'm glad I got chin here. Thanks my pleasure,
brother. My pleasure. And um, it's always cool seeing you at the store.
You're funny. Motherfucking likewise. Thanks for that. And uh,
I wish all the best. So tell everybody what your Instagram, what is the,
it's a he-man war. So just my name, uh, Twitter. Same He-man or,
and then I'm a special on Amazon called, there's no business like show business.
So I just want people to watch that. I didn't like too many shows on Amazon.
Yeah. But it was acquired, so it wasn't like an original idea.
Everyone knew that was going down. Yeah. Yeah. All right brother.
Thank you very much. [inaudible] bye everybody.